Film Courage: Brooks, before you moved
to Hollywood what was the picture you
had in your mind of what it meant to
be a working Hollywood screenwriter?
Brooks Elms, Teacher/Consultant/Screenwriter:
That's a great question if
before I went to Hollywood my thought
of being a working screenwriter is
sort of non-stop five projects at a time, this
one, that one, the other one and finishing one
and getting on to another one. I think that's
pretty much what I would think back then.
Film Courage: When you were attending NYU or
even before you had this vision that it would be
non-stop work phone ringing people wanting to have
meetings maybe yeah yeah so yeah the idea made it
was um what's so interesting is that a lot of
people talk about oh have you made it if you
broke it in or whatever um and it's it's kind
of amorphous when you go what does that mean
to you that you made it and people usually go
screen cybers i don't really know so that was
certainly the case for me i mean when i started um
i was making movies with my friends in high school
and um it was so much fun and i just was like
look nothing in my life is more fun than this
how can i do this as much as possible and
then i was like oh well i can go to study
at nyu film school and i went and so and then at
that point i just i would have probably if i was
pushed to define making it i would have thought
yeah making something that's widely released
and everybody knows you and your whatever and my
thought was yeah you're sort of working constantly
um that's probably how i how i thought about it
back then in terms of the process of the work
did you think that it would just be as
easy as sitting down and you know having
a glass of wine or whiskey or whatever and just
music in the background and it's all pours out
or did you realize that it would be more
painstaking uh that's interesting um
well because the way i started um with my friends
it was there was a social aspect of it it was like
i wanted to do this with my friends i liked them
and we had this idea to do together and it was
fun so there was a very team oriented start to
when i made movies and then on my own i would
do my own experiments and then as i got to film
school i learned that expressing my own voice
was really powerful and satisfying in a way so i
became pretty good at um working on other people's
projects and supporting them uh co-writing and
collaborating in groups and you know leading
following and everything in between um so the um
so the process was sort of intoxicating engaging
fascinating and like layered and levels and so
i um so yeah so the creativity the creative part
of it and the process oh it always came pretty
naturally and was deeply engrossing to me so
um there were things that back then i would
consider hard or difficult or whatever um
about the process but the way i approach it now
it's never hard it's always easy and it's because
i frame it in a way that makes it easy whereas
back then i didn't know how to do that so i was
generally having fun but very often going wow this
is so hard this is difficult i was looking at the
the what was going on in certain ways without
realizing that was undermining the power of my
process and when did you realize that it was
much different than your first visions of what
a working successful hollywood screenwriter
is yeah that's that's a good question so i
right out of nyu film school when i was 22 years
old i made a rote directed and produced feature um
and then we kind of ran out of money
and it took a couple years to kind
of get edited and put out there and i
ended up taking it on this really fun um
college tour because it was a college it was a
movie about my friends on the nyu soccer team
and how we were pretty good at playing soccer
but really good at drinking after games
and that's probably a more interesting
encapsulation of what it actually was
but like there were some good aspects of it
but it was really kind of like a graduate level
student feature it was kind of weird 22.
um but i but i took that film to um all
these different college campuses on this
college tour and i played it for uh for
for a month in new york city at this off-broadway
space called new york city's gorilla cinema that
we created and it was a lot of fun so um so
i was getting a first-hand experience of how
challenging it can be to get people in the seats
you know i did this movie people that saw it liked
it for what it was um and it was like well geez
how do i how does that work how do you get people
it's not just i made a movie and everybody shows
up and it's not exactly like you know it didn't
get into sundance so i didn't have the you know
kevin smith experience or richard linklater those
guys um uh so um but it was the whole thing was
fun the the craziest promotion we did in at that
time at one point even me or my friend that was
doing it because actually in addition to screening
my movie we screened my friend's independent
feature too so like mine was odd nights his
was even nights we both did it together so we
were both promoting these two independent films
together at one point we even put like a gorilla
suit on around the street we're doing all sorts
of things and um so how uh so i got a firsthand
experience of what it's like to be the business
part of it how do you get people how difficult
is it to tell people about your movie and get
them to care about it and who is going to care
about this movie because i wasn't thinking about
that i was just thinking about my own voice and
something that felt true to me at the time you
know for good and for bad how is that picture of
being a working hollywood screenwriter different
now well i think the creative part of it is the
same i'm no more or less creative than i ever was
and my love of it is basically the same but
i'm able to look at the process in a way that's
deeper and more fun and easier and so the
quality of my choices that are going to be
more impactful they come more often and they come
at a greater flow and when i have the ideas that
are just a little bumpy or not quite as strong
i don't get hung up on them so it's sort of the
grace of my efficiency has increased significantly
and the way i think about it and the way i allow
myself to have more joy more often so my creative
process is profoundly different although like if
you asked me one single question i had to
have a creative answer to that now or when
i was 22 would be kind of the same but my craft
is profoundly different and how that relates to
the way i see working writers you know and myself
it's it's my creativity will be that i'll be hired
by producers to work on some sort of project and
um and then i show up and we're we see it through
fruition and it just and there's sometimes
overlapping projects and there's sometimes lulls
in between and then when there's a lull in between
i'm writing my own new spec material so i'm always
writing and there's joys of writing my own spec
material and there's joys of writing on assignment
you know i mean the money part of the assignment
guaranteed is nice but it's really the deeper joy
there for me is i'm working with a team of people
and we have to find out a way where i'm loving it
and they're loving it um i mean ultimately they
get the final say but they hire me because they
really want my my view right you know because um
there's something i did in either a sample or the
way i pitched an idea to them that they felt like
yeah this you know this guy can really contribute
so um so it's that creative flow that i told you
about that's fully there when i'm doing spec work
and it's it's playing well with others in
a sandbox it's really kind of that simple
and there's a whole complication to it but it
really is that simple so um uh and and i guess
the other thing is that there's a piece with
the sort of freelance nature of it the feast
and famine the busy and then the flow and then and
the the paradox is the more relaxed you are about
when projects come when doors close and how
you respond to them um the easier things happen
and the times in my career when i was
like hey sex i got to make it happen
i was inadvertently pushing it away you know
it's like the um the cool kid in high school you
know this person is like you know he you know all
the guys liked him the girls liked him he was he
wasn't doing anything he was just kind of cool you
know and so um we all have that cool person inside
us um and maybe some of you were that cool and
the funny is if you talk to one of those people um
they might not make they might not even have
seen themselves as the cool person but like
um but there absolutely is that part of all of us
that has that sort of charisma our own authentic
charisma and when we show up with that part of
ourselves in a meeting in the um the outreach part
of the game um where we're there's no desperation
we're not boring we're just um at ease and we're
ourselves what ends up happening is we're um
it's about connecting dots so that we make
ourselves the exact dot that we want to be
and then the buyer of the script is the exact
they're looking for that dot and then that's
how they connect so um yeah i don't know if
that makes sense it does and i want to talk
more about law of attraction and things later
um yeah and and you had some great videos on
your channel about that as it relates to story
what if things aren't so joyous and you know
that in in terms of staying with a project and
playing well in the sandbox there are going to
be times where you're challenged and maybe you
didn't think of that before when you were at nyu
because it was all fun and everybody was sort of
you were in this together and you could have
drinks afterwards or whatever it was you knew
each other well but now the stakes are different
how do you how do you view it now because things
don't always go well in sandbox yeah so um
well my experience at nyu was was awesome
and very competitive um at least because i'm
a bit of a person so maybe i was bringing that
to it um so it was it was lots of fun and it
was a great experience but it was you know
there was actually about half the people there
were kind of still figuring stuff out and then
the other half were kind of killers and they
were they were getting after it um so um
to me that side of it those pressures were were
similar but to your point that's different like
you know nyu is like we paid the money we get the
thing that's it in the marketplace it's like we
put up or we don't get employed you know what
i mean so so there's those pressures that are
really different but ultimately it's it's the same
game it's like i either have an idea that's going
to contribute to this producer's vision of what
they want to do with the project or don't and
so um when i show up and have a meeting and
share my take on something or um or they've
already hired me and i do a draft it's like i just
i don't can do the best that i can do and then um
they look at it and and then we go from there i
mean it's um so it's so yes the the doors close
um and oftentimes people will frame
that situation of a closed door as
a challenge or terrible or this or that or the
other and um i understand that and i have empathy
for that and it's just um it's paying attention to
the wrong thing and it's actually a self-imposed
limitation to kind of even think of it that
way you just say um you just count the wins you
know this is a win this is a win this is a win
and then the winds stop at some point but like
um and it sounds like pollyanna-ish because it
is and yet um as i've tried that sort of mindset
it's just hey it feels better it's real fun and
it works better because again you're shifting to
that cool kid in high school everything's just it
says okay you work it out it's either this okay
yeah this door closed doesn't matter there's
one behind it and then okay that one goes fine
then there's one behind it and the more we focus
on that it really does the paradox is the more
we're not attached to when the door finally
opens the faster they open the watch pot never
boils kind of that's right it absolutely never
boils in hollywood you cannot be desperate and
you can't be boring um and so uh the way to not be
desperate and the way to not be boring is the way
to not be boring is being authentic to yourself
and the way to not be desperate is realize that
it's okay it's gonna work out the universe is on
the job you do you do your stuff i go up i i make
the best creative choices i can i'm either i'm
specking material i'm working with this partner
or whatever and um and that's it it's going
to work out did you always think like this
no not at all that was the thing so um i was
always i always loved it right and i loved
it and i was very productive there's some people
that have like a motor and they go and go and go
and that's sort of how my sort of you know i made
50 short film experiments before i even got to nyu
and then um at nyu a ton more right so i was just
i could just go and um i would what most people do
see what's going on out there and if things
were going well i would feel good if things were
not going well the door closed i would feel bad
right so um and that is a terrible way to live
in general i mean the way most people do it in
a sense because um it hooks us into the roller
coaster and this business is very much that sort
of cyclical up down there's there's these things
happening beyond what we can completely control so
um so what i would do is you know hustle and get
excited and kind of effort my way this that and
you know i could make things happen and things
were good and i would progress but the progression
of my career literally happens so much faster when
i'm i'm focused and i have a goal and i
know where i'm going but i'm not um i'm
i'm just not hooked into it it's gonna happen
or it's not this is gonna be i'm just i'm i'm
good with whatever happens and it's um and it's
a practice you have to be able to practice that
in little ways and in big ways and as i in my
career was able to practice that more often a my
existential experience of life got better i just
felt better about me and um and milestones got
crossed just much faster this milestone that most
and all it was easy no effort everything's easy
um and it's it's a practice and so um yeah so back
in the day i didn't know any different so i didn't
i didn't know to do it that way and i have a a an
accountability partner who's who's a professional
tv writer and i remember a few years ago he said
he got this job writing on the show and he was
like yeah you know there was no effort it was so
easy i just um you know i didn't have to chase it
down and my mind was kind of hurting so what do
you mean what what's wrong with this i spent my
whole life hustling and making things happen and
he just i realized that he was in this place where
he was a valuing not hustling not efforting
letting things be easy and i didn't realize that
was possible and if it was possible that it could
actually work and it could work it actually felt
better and so in talking to him and then reading a
lot and you know this is sort of law of attraction
stuff and you know you know not getting caught
up in some of the woo-woo aspect of those things
but really looking at the tangible more grounded
aspects of them and then trying them and as i
tried them everything got better i it felt felt
better i enjoyed it more my creative process got
easier more powerful more consistent
my job became i get up and i'm happy
and um and then oh yeah what's going on out there
and uh is secondary you know what i mean and it's
again it's not 100 i'm not like all rainbows and
butterflies but um if you talk to people that i
work with um they'll pretty much say that most of
the time i'm feeling pretty happy and balanced and
and it's because i'm in the habit i'm in the
habit of whatever whatever um whatever happens
to me out there i respond in a way that just um is
aware of the of the sort of the abundance and the
bigness and the greatness that's there around
some of the challenges and you know the pieces
of the challenges does that make sense it does
and balance is something that's very important
to you this is sort of the scales it is it is
i you know um yeah i would say yes certainly
certainly flow is the word that comes up for
me that when i'm in a state of flow that's when
it's easy it's effortless it's just fun and
it's like you get that time warp experience
where you played a lot of sports did you have
to retrain yourself because you said before that
you were competitive is that helpful uh i love
that you brought up sports because um i've been
so i played soccer in college i was captain of the
nyu team and intensely competitive um and nyu is
a division three school so division one schools
are like they're all about it and division three
schools are students that also play right so but
i wanted to study the film school so i was there
but i was really competitive too so um uh this
idea of how much winning matters and how to um
sort of make sense of winning in
the scope of things and and how to
it it absolutely fascinates me and it completely
relates to this whole idea of mindset because
again the same paradox that we talked about with
hollywood it's like if you're too desperate for
something you're actually pushing it away and in
sports if you're too desperate for hitting a free
throw shot or something happening in soccer or
whatever it is you can't you have you got to be
loose and you got to have that flow it's this it's
exactly the same thing and that's actually one of
the ways i was able to sort of find value in the
law of attraction ideas um you know and sort of
just you know not not pay too much attention to
the metaphysical parts of it because they might be
true but if it's metaphysical i can't really sort
of measure it or make sense of it but i knew damn
sure that when i played sports if my mindset
was confident and easy and active and flowing
the numbers my stats were much better than if
i was freaked out or if i was worried about
outcome what if we lose what if i miss what if
hollywood doesn't come walking right so it's all
the what ifs what ifs and so um it absolutely
was a direct connection for me to sort of
take what i learned as an athlete and then what
i because i've also coached a lot of kids in in
sports as well my own kids and i even coached a
high school soccer team for a season which was
amazing and um i love that mindset stuff
it just makes it makes a big difference
certainly in sports absolutely entertainment
and really it crosses over pretty much anywhere
should a new writer look at writing as a
fun endeavor or should they really check
themselves in the beginning and say okay is this
something i want to take on the time commitment
time away from maybe friends and family maybe
there are going to be parts that won't be so
joyous it's a great question and yeah absolutely
do it because it's fun there's no other reason to
do it and if it's not completely fun do anything
else you know find what is fun for you if there
was something that was a hobby for you that
you love but you didn't want to take it on as
a career could you say the same for writers
maybe they just want to write for the sheer
joy of it for creating characters but they don't
want the pressure of having to pitch and have
to pay their car payment based on
whether they sell a script or not
yeah of course yeah yeah no that's um one of the
most satisfying experiences i get from writing
yeah the fact that i get paid
well to write is separate from
my experience of of writing i mean if
i didn't make a dime from anything i
wrote the rest of my life i would still
write i mean it's because it's it's so
deeply satisfying in terms of executing my
vision for how life occurs to me what are my
deepest challenges what are my um what are the
insights that have sort of gotten me through
different parts of my life how do i how did i make
a transformation from this stage to that stage i
mean that's what we do in any screenplay and if
i'm writing about an astronaut or this or that
you know i've never been an astronaut but i've
written about several but it's the emotional
journey of those characters that's it's as
personal to me as if i'm writing in a journal so
um if somebody is drawn to screenwriting for the
sheer joy of it that's absolutely what they should
be doing and they and nobody really should be
worrying about the money side of it if it's so
fun for you to write a screenplay and so fun for
you to share it with anybody and so fun for them
to say i love it and so fun for them to sort of
give you feedback and so fun for you to take that
feedback and find a way to serve them even better
and so fun to keep that going then absolutely that
person should allow the professional part of it
to come to them and if they stop at any point
in that path and they're happy just writing
it for themselves and showing it to nobody
that's great i mean it's really about what makes
them happy is that the litmus test is it fun yeah
really so is that how you approach most things
in life though it has to be where it's not
creating huge amounts of stress for you yeah um
absolutely i've read a wonderful book years ago
about ben and jerry's ice cream company um i love
i loved it so much i cried when i finished uh
reading it and it was because they to my mind
um had a beautiful vision of fun and business
you know it's show and its business and the way
they articulated it was this double bottom line
anything they did had had to be fun and it
had to be profitable right and the truth is
if you approach it the right way you absolutely
can do both and if you're not seeing the way
to do both have something be profitable
and lucrative and fun and easy you're not
looking in the right direction it's probably like
right behind you and you have to turn around and
look someplace else but it really is and how in
my writing process or my life certainly things
come up and it feels there's a resistance or
something's not easy and then that's just a
reminder to go dude it's you know you're this is
you're forcing it it's too much and then i go okay
well what's the easy what's the easy way what's
the easy way and that's oftentimes stopping and
breathing or we're not thinking about it think
about something else that is easy in the moment
and then going to that and then um when i
hold those spaces open the easy ways come
have you had people challenge
you students mentees that say
work isn't supposed to be fun
aside from this interview where i'm
playing the devil's advocate i love it well
it's um i mean that's the standard right so um
and and and so it's where and and people are
people have to i can sit here and tell them
this or that or the other and uh they they need
to figure it out for themselves and they need to
try it if they're interested and not try it if
they're not interested it's not right for them
if they hear it and it's too crazy and and you
know then that's fine so um i have no interest
in um convincing somebody of anything i mean if i
you know when i used to teach this class that you
said ucla extension i would absolutely speak to
these ideas um and they wouldn't really challenge
me i'm sure some people were very skeptical and
some people were flat out like that's crazy that
can't work and that's fine you know it certainly
can't work for them if that's the way they think
um and it might work for you even
if you're skeptical if you try it
and you say okay i think it's probably not going
to work but i'm going to be open to it and and
i i might try it and you see and what will happen
at least in my experience is um a it feels better
and if nothing else if the uh if there's no law
of attraction if it's all hui and um the odds of
something happening are exactly the same but your
approach to life feels better and you've got the
same odds it's worth doing it so my invitation to
anybody who's skeptical is i honor the skepticism
try it out see if you enjoy it more see if the
odds are at least the same of getting what you
want as soon as you want and and see if you don't
have the experience that i've had and i've seen
pretty much everybody that embraces the theory
have you actually get things faster because i'm
open to opportunities in a way that's different
when i'm closed off and i'm focused on oh
crap this is going to happen i'm scared
of that or this didn't happen or i'm
not good enough or i'm an imposter or all
these things these voices that come up um
you know it's good to notice that they're there
and just let them go and if we spend too much time
on them or we just went anytime just just notice
them like the wind and let it go through because
the more we sort of give them attention
the more we're sort of limiting ourselves
so you're also not attached to other people's
opinions it sounds like too which is a beautiful
place to be it's the best place to be because
um my i'm here to serve my audience so um
if i have um you know so so you know i'll have
a bunch of ideas in my script that i've put down
and when i get feedback i'm it's not me getting
feedback it's like these ideas came to me they're
in service to the audience and my job is to sort
of get out of the way it's whatever the best idea
from anywhere to better serve the audience and so
when i get feedback and criticism if there's any
peace in that that's going to be more of service
to the audience awesome and if it's not going
to be in service okay fine thanks for at least
you know trying to give me feedback you know so
uh does that answer your question it does yeah how
did the book save the cat change your life oh it
made a huge impact on my life because up to the
point where i picked up that book i was muscling
my way through a writing process i'd taken robert
mckee's course and a bunch of others and i liked
it i love theory it's fascinating to me and i went
down where you filmed school so i got nothing but
theory there um and uh and i'd made i think i just
finished like the fifth feature screenplay that
i wrote and that one was the third independent
feature that i made and it was um it was another
personal drama and it was good for what it was
but it was this sort of self-imposed ceiling that
i put on my career it was um i loved the subject
matter and i'm proud of it but it was so obscure
that um it just all the real greatness of those
ideas were not as accessible as they could be
had i sort of reordered the ideas or built them in
a different way and so i finally this is probably
my mid-thirties i i um got the humility to say
okay maybe hollywood knows a few things about
story structure that i should actually figure out
and again i've taken these other courses but mckee
is great but he's so certain his theories are all
these different really cool pieces but there was
no system at least that i could get from his his
sort of uh weekend lecture but i liked it i think
i might have done twice in my 20s blake snyder's
system to me was an absolute life changer game
changer completely because he has his own genre
system he's got his own um step-by-step process um
and uh and and i took his after i loved the book
i took his weekend seminar and his energy was
delightful just playful fun really accessible
super smart so i learned from him personally i
learned from his theory and i still use it now
and so it just it completely revolutionized the
way that i think about concept think about
structure think about process i mean it's
a night and day difference and what i use now and
what i when i mentor writers what i help them with
is a variation of of blake's system that i've
tailored to my own sort of professional process
and it's just a step-by-step process of really
focusing on those story design choices because
what most writers will do is they'll go i
got an idea for a movie and maybe they'll
have a character or two or whatever and then
they jump ahead to um writing the script
and now you're writing the script they write like
try to write the final draft of the script and
it's a fiasco that process is so difficult to get
right and again everybody has their own process so
that's the one you're using and it's working for
you great in my experience for my own work and
working with a lot of writers um it's it's there's
just so many missed opportunities um from focusing
i break it down into seven steps be similar to to
blake's system so i it's a simple way to say it
is i tell the story i get them to tell the story
or do my own work in one sentence and then five
sentences and then 15 sentences which is like
blake's 15 beats and then 40 sentences which is
basically a sentence for each scene in the movie
more or less those are the first four steps and
then the other three are screenplay draft steps
so you have get it down get it good and get it
great um and and it's and it's a problem all those
those things are they're steps but they're really
almost like um there's seven different ways the
audience is craving answers about your story
and most writers that aren't like fully firing
on all pistons aren't answering those questions
as deeply as they could so i'm good at doing that
in my work at least enough and then i get feedback
and i figure out how to do it even better and when
i work with other people i just make sure that
they're fully answering those questions and then
when they get to the screenplay writing part um
get it down as just as quickly as you can you're
almost like formatting it i usually tell like
write a treatment in that fourth stage after i
do like the 40 sort of sentences for each scene
i'll kind of write that into a treatment five
pages 15 pages and that was copy and paste that
into the screenplay format and then i'm
just almost reformatting it cliche this
cliche that doesn't matter bomb but just kind of
scaffolding that's that that that um step um five
and then step six is get it good it's not great
it's just kind of okay you got a mess of cliches
and whatever but you kind of organize it a little
bit just kind of easy breezy momentum flow and
then after a few drafts of that you're like okay
this is working you're getting good feedback
again we're in the reaction game so it's
not enough if you want to be professional
that um that i dislike it's like i have to like
it and then it's coming across other people and
they're saying it's great um and then when
you're getting that good then you get into
that fine tuning safe get it get it great so
it's gonna get it down get it good get it great
and what i see most mistakes they make so this is
that seven step process inspired by blake's people
will get a loose idea right here like step one and
it'll jump to like step seven and it's a fiasco
and even if they finish the script um you can see
it the script's is a mess and sometimes you know
if they tell me what their script idea is in
one sentence um it'll it'll also be a mess and
i can just like just by seeing the one sentence
i know the same problems they have in a hundred
page script when you say some new writers aren't
good at providing answers to questions about their
characters is it because they themselves don't
know the answers or they're not good at relaying
that information um to the audience almost
everybody just hasn't thought about it enough
um i mean there's some people that have a laser
bead on who these people are and and um and
they're just and they're sort of developing their
skill in terms of articulating on that page with
pagecraft um but most of the people just um it's
just a little fuzzy they haven't spent enough time
going wait a minute who is that character um for
example i'm writing this this this script right
now and um it was interesting because i had this
problem with sort of the plotting in the first
act and i couldn't quite work it out and i was you
know i was like well tried to figure out this and
i tried to figure out that way i couldn't do it
and then taking my own advice i was like oh just
relax and do something else what is easy now so i
went over to this and i was getting this note from
this one character and they were like who's this
guy why what is he doing and i was like oh yeah
you're right he's i kind of had a sense of him but
how can i sort of clarify it sharpen the focus on
him and then when i did um i was like oh i know
this guy and he's he's great he's so swarmy and
he's just he's almost like this paul giamatti type
character and i was like oh he's so fun to write
and then once i got that clarity i realized oh
i need a new scene in the first act for this guy
because i had it previously happening off screen
but once i got more clarity on who that character
was i added that scene and then magically it took
care of that plot issue that i couldn't get before
so that's a real world example of how i totally
used the easy way to solve something i was using
it the hard way at first i tried it this way tried
it this way and i then was like oh dude yeah no
there's an easy way don't force it and i just went
over to something else and was like okay and then
boom would you say before you read save the cat or
took some of blake snyder's courses that you were
bad at structure that's a great question i just
had a very rudimentary beginning middle and end
sense of structure and i the problem is i had kind
of too many halfway ideas about it you know this
guru that guru the other and i i remember one
time i made the spreadsheet probably i was in
my 20s i'd probably written two or three and i was
it was literally like 50 or 60 boxes and like this
question and that question and it was just a
mess of like there was no connective tissue to it
so when i found blake snyder's system which
had really deep actionable insights about
why movies from hollywood work and a system step
by step to sort of move through it it just it all
came together for me how do you teach structure
to your students i teach structure to my students
generally starting with blake's method so
um we talk about concept we talk about um
uh five story well blake talks blake goes
from concept to 15 what he calls beats
but they're not even really beats it's um he's
what he'll have is in his 15 beats are there's
some turning points and there's sequences um and
then he's got opening image closing images which
is a great bookending device and then he calls out
your b story which is your second most significant
thread and then he um he talks about the theme
how it should be stated early on and overtly um
and and that's it so there's a few things that
are um but it's kind of a weird word so i i kind
of think of his sort of 15 story but they're all
pertinent it's like i for sure am writing a better
screenplay when i have good answers for each of
those 15 things whatever you want to call them
the thing one of the things i added to to my
process that he doesn't really talk about is
starting with you know the log line and
premises is huge and then 15 beats is
really helpful but in between those two there's
i i do five sentences so act one act two a or
what blake calls fun and games your midpoint
turn and then act two b and then act three
um so it's more or less the three-act structure
but it's broken out into these pieces i mean this
is a turning point but like it's so important to
kind of call it out and so sometimes when i'm even
coming up with a movie idea for the in the very
beginning i'll kind of have a couple pieces of
the concept and i'll actually maybe sketch it out
the five to five sentences but it's all easy it's
kind of like well oh i know it's going to end and
i'm not quite sure about this part of that part so
i just fill in what i know and go to the other
parts and just kind of play with it and then it
just comes together if it's a good idea and if
it's easy it'll come together and if it's not
coming together at least right now i just
put it aside do something else that is easy
and then you said if to further flesh it out 40
you you do like you number one through 40 and then
you have one sentence be each scene that's right
so for that like that's my step four process right
it'll um and most movies will have about 40 scenes
you know plus or minus 5 or 10 or whatever so um i
want to get a sense of i'll expand those 15 beats
to like the 40 scenes and if it's 35 i don't care
it's fine i just note oh i'm a little bit short
because here's the thing the thing with structure
that throws off a lot of people is especially
people that aren't comfortable with it yet they're
like i don't want to follow those rules it's
confining me and they use that exact tone of voice
so but what what's most instructive to me and
how i also work with with um you know my mentees
or students or whatever i um it's the expectations
of the audience the audience is absolutely craving
uh beginning middle and end they're craving your
your break into act two to happen someplace around
you know the late 20s you know 25 minutes 20
you know blake says 27 minutes so it doesn't
have to be on that page but um but if i write
it and it's five pages after that or ten pages
i'm aware of that and it's the opportunity to go
i know the audience is expecting this around 27
do i have enough legit have i earned their trust
to go longer am i so it's totally fine to sort of
go against their expectations but i want to
do it mindfully or it's an opportunity to go
huh i'm you know my i'm breaking into two at that
you know page 35 is there something i can oh you
know what i totally can cut this whole scene or
trim this down and then i get it closer so it's
an opportunity to very definitively look at what
the audience is expecting in a very concrete way
and go do i want to play two audience expectations
here or go against it so specifically with the 40
you know 40 sentences for the scenes you know
again plus or minus five or ten or whatever um
i'll do that and then i i um so i so i have the
sort of bone structure of how i can go and i often
put them on index cards and a board in my my home
office and um and uh and then i'd like to go from
there before i go to the script to actually write
a treatment as well for two reasons one is um
the uh those 40 cards are really good for sort
of structural choices and sort of thread flow
and that sort of thing but they don't get the
feeling really of the story so that's why i go to
a treatment and then the second reason is you know
nobody's going to look at my 40 beats and really
get what i'm doing so if i want feedback and
i get a lot of feedback in the treatment stage
i write the treatment and then i can you
know five pages 10 pages whatever it takes
the screenplay that i'm working on now i actually
did three drafts of the treatment got really
good feedback between everyone then realized
that i wanted to change the protagonist from
one character to the other and then did three
more drafts of the treatment and then felt it
was good and then i'm into the screenplay so by
the time i get to the screenplay my first draft
you know it's not really a first draft because
i've spent so much time designing the story doing
the treatment it's it's by probably a typical you
know fifth draft or tenth draft for other people
at what point should a writer have earned the
audience's trust and if it's not there by that
point it's going to be hard to get it later
page one um you know um i mean i'll look at
a screenplay and literally line one i'm already
going really does this person have the job i can't
look i can't look at one line and definitively say
but i but i'll tell you what you give me you show
me the first sentence or maybe not it can't be
just the slug line the slug line in one sentence
of um you know you should it was interesting
but if i saw the slug line in one sentence of
10 screenplays i bet you i could tell you
how much i'm going to like that screenplay
um within probably 80 percent likelihood like i
can see a professional crafted line in just two
sentences um i don't do that that harshly whatever
like you know at least give them a page or two
if i'm gonna sort of evaluate something but like
um there's just so many choices i mean you're
talking it's it's sort of like poetry in a sense
where every word counts and you can often when
you've done it for so long realize i don't need
that word i don't need that word i could subtract
to subtract you get that white space flowing
on the page so you can um just very efficiently
and then muscular word choices and specific words
there's so much to be seen again so i'll even say
this if you take a if you take even the way
the slug line is formatted and the way they're
talking about the time of day and those things
those are choices and um and amateurs tend to
make one pool of choices and professionals tend to
make other ones again tendencies but like yeah i
would think 80 of the time i could look at two
lines and i could feel like this is probably a
professional or somebody at least writing at the
professional level and so if that page one is not
is not up to par it's going to be very difficult
almost impossible maybe to gain that trust
for the reader or audience later on so yes but
it's not binary right so what will happen is um
you know all anybody who's spending the hours and
hours of time writing a screenplay has some sort
of talent you know i mean they have something
going on right so you know i don't think i've
ever read a screenplay that had like zero like
nothing right there's something you know so um
but what will happen is i'll get to page one if
i was just picking up a random script from random
amateur writer and i look at page one again i
look at line two or three and i'm already knowing
yeah this person's probably you know from the
scale of totally professional to total beginner
within two sentences i know that okay this is
probably where this person is and i'll get to
the end of the first page and now i have a 90
chance or 95 chance of knowing where they are
now that being said if i'm a production company
and i'm looking for a thriller and my friend
said he read he read this thriller and it was
amazing and i read page one and i'm going okay
my friends i trust my friend he's saying it's
amazing i'm looking at this thing it's not
a really a professional level written thing it's
kind of amateurish i might not toss in the trash
at that point i might go um okay but you're it's
it's you're leaning against it you're sort of
you're minimizing it so it's important not to
see it in a binary way where it's this or that
but at a certain point in hollywood it will be
binded they'll give you first of all they're not
going to read the script unless in one sentence
you can pitch the story and then they'll go oh
yeah that's worth my time then they'll give it a
couple pages and then toss it when it's not any
good it's more than just formatting issues
though you said it's also like word choices
and you know it's not just how much white's on the
page or even it's all those things right because
it's the screenplay format is so um it's kind of
clunky it's a clunky format right um you know uh
the way the slug line works and it just it's
sort of yeah i mean whereas pros it's just
like a waterfall of words you know and i don't
even write prose but like um but the screenplay
format is just it's blocky and so because there's
those limitations um when you get really familiar
with the format you can see people very quickly
making choices within this sort of format that are
you know different good or different bad or
or different inexperienced you know there was
a script a specser that came out a couple years
ago that was doing all sorts of crazy things with
fonts and craziness and um i love a little of
that when it's organic and it feels inspired
um but this script i i you know i wanted
to ring somebody's neck after about 30
pages i was like you know oh wow cool
idea and i like it because they were
really stretching the bounds of the format um
and then it felt like to me it was a it was
at least to me for my sensibility was it felt like
a trick or a gimmick it wasn't that they um to my
mind i wasn't able to find my way in emotionally
to what their vision was you know so um
so i don't know i mean um but they you know
certainly made a splash doing that and um and
who knows maybe other people really liked it
then that's that's great that's the thing is
it's a subjective business so um you know i have
very refined and and strongly held beliefs but i'm
just one opinion you know i mean we you know
we might disagree about what won the oscar in
any given year you love it i hate it or vice versa
and that's a movie that's produced and heralded as
the best that we've got and stark disagreements
so um certainly any spec script by any writer
um you know it just needs to be i
mean if i'm working with somebody i'm
what's interesting about that is if i'm working
with somebody my opinion doesn't even really
come up because it doesn't matter my what i
do is or even when i write my own stuff it's
i'm an advocate for their audience
and i gently in an inspired way just
ask questions when i think that their audience
is going to be wondering you know why you know
i think your audience is going to want a more
cohesive idea here you know what if like you're
all i know your audience is craves to have a sense
of irony in your concept you know i know your
audience might you know when you're thinking about
constructing your log line they want a character's
goal that is just driven it's powerful and
there's these stakes and then there's a conflict
so i just sort of i articulate what i'm in my
experience i believe their audience is going to be
thinking and that gives the people i work with um
a really fine sort of goal post for them to shoot
at and that's the great thing is that um whenever
you whatever your writing process is or whatever
your support system is you you want to have a
really high quality feedback loop so you can stay
focused on the task at hand in an inspired way and
move as quickly as possible what slows up writers
is they don't have a quality feedback loop system
they kind of figure out their own they might read
a book but they can read a book and they don't
know if they're actually applying the book or not
um and then they might have all sorts of hang-ups
about getting feedback because this person yelled
at them they take toxic or they or their you know
they take too much feedback and they drown her out
their own voices all sorts of nightmares but like
having a world-class um feedback and development
system is absolutely one of the best things i've
done for my career um i mean and i'm so good at it
i can even i can even take to somebody that's like
a layperson that doesn't even know the business
and i can ask them for feedback in a certain
way and it gives me a high quality echo of
what's going on if you just hand them if i hand
my sister the script and my sister's awesome
and uh she used to always watch our high school
movies and she has belting laughs we called her
like the laugh anchor but anyway but in general
if i was to give her my script and she would
basically say oh i liked it or i didn't like
it right that's sort of base level analysis um
but what you can do is take even a lay person
if you direct them in the right way with how
you ask for feedback so you know uh you know for
my sister i could say was there any um what was
your favorite character was um which character
do you feel like you wanted to know more about
or needed more sort of development which scenes
felt like you didn't need them right these are
questions she absolutely can answer um
definitively from her opinion and she would have
almost never thought to tell that to me if i just
gave it to her because she's a lay person right
she's just going oh i like this line of dialogue
or this was great or i didn't like it or whatever
so um so whatever writers use for their feedback
system whether i have a writer's group or a coach
or accountability partner or whatever works for
them i would invite them to have it be a really
high quality echo because we're anticipating we're
in the reaction business we're anticipating that
reaction from the audience and the better that
feedback loop can be and the quicker it can be
the faster our career will move forward what do
you say to screenwriters who are insulted or feel
that it's too rush or you're not respecting the
craft when you can tell by page one or even really
halfway down the page whether it's a professional
level screenplay what do you say to those people
um it's a great question and i know a lot of
writers um feel very strongly about that like
how could you even tell my screenplay is any good
if you've only read you know you know one page or
even a couple lines that's really ridiculous um
okay no i'm fine uh you can disagree with me all
you want um i believe i am familiar enough with
this stuff um and i see patterns and indicators of
success and i see a correlation um you know
and i and i believe it and not only in me
every experienced right every like 100 percent
of the not 100 maybe 95 98 of experienced writers
that i know absolutely feel like again it's not
binary they can't read a line or a page and go
this is definitively crap or definitely good but
you know you know all my peers i i absolutely
would put money on them looking at a particular
random script and after reading one page they all
for sure could say this is an amateur level writer
or this is a you know probably not even 100 but i
think for the most part and it's just because
there's what i think the people they get upset
about is they don't they don't know what they
don't know they don't realize how many choices
they're making on the page and that's
probably why they get pissed off is because
they're going okay the character gets in the car
or and such and such happens but right but like
you know i've written 25 30 screenplays so
i've and and that's just like finished ones
not to mention some of those drafts were
15 20 30 drafts and probably another 30
treatment so like i've been in the game for
a while i've seen a lot of stuff and and you
just get familiar with the same thing over and
over and over again so um so what they so a a
person writing their first second third screenplay
for them they're just focusing on basic oh there's
a guy i see him in the car and they just say
guy gets in the car but like you know i'm seeing
that same line and i'm thinking of on 10 levels
you know i'm thinking of it on how many words
the how muscular the words are the cadence what's
going on before that and after um you know how um
you know uh symbolically how does it relate to
the theme you know and again i don't do all that
on the first draft but by the time i get to that
end draft every line i've thought about dozens and
dozens of times with those different lenses and
because i have that much familiarity with every
single line in my screenplay um i can read a line
from an amateur who's probably looked at that line
two times three times five times and when i look
at something two times five times it's like that
it's not really it does you know it looks like a
rough rock it doesn't look like a gem when i've
seen something a dozen times 20 times especially
after all my experience it shines in a different
way you just the magic comes through it in a
way that's different so um even if you were to
look at you know my first draft and my last draft
you're just seeing a rougher edge with all those
things and that's just part of the process
and that's another thing is that a lot of um
amateur writers they won't do as many drafts
as they need to to really shine or they'll
do the drafts but they're changing the wrong
damn things that don't even make a difference
which kind of breaks my heart because um they've
got enough creativity and they love it enough but
they don't know the way through the forest so they
end up spending years and years wandering around
and then some of them quit it's terrible can
you give me an example of of poorly used cadence
um so poorly used that's an interesting question
poorly used cadence in dialogue would be something
that doesn't sound authentic to that character
right usually it's the writer's own voice they
all sound like you know me and you know what the
truth is um i am fine writing my early drafts
pretty much with everybody my in my in my voice
i mean why not i mean if i have an ear for them
fine i'll do it but like even if the thing
i'm writing now has this british character
and you know i'm doing kind of a you
know whatever loose idea of a british
i'll imagine like a guy from hell's kitchen or
like pierce morgan what do you say but like i
don't sweat it it's sort of like it's more like me
kind of doing a bad british accent or whatever you
know that's kind of the cadence that i'm hearing
and then as i get to draft drafts i'll maybe bring
in a friend who's british and go dude can you take
a look at this and he'll go yeah we would never
say this we would never do that you know or like
when i was writing astronauts it was great to um
get real astronauts and go um yeah we described
this stuff and we're kind of like pulling it off
stuff we got on the internet i don't you know
do tell me and it was really exciting every
time they're like no no that's legit that's
right i was like wow it is it's amazing so um
cadence for a line of description is really
where your voice comes from as a screenwriter
um you know hemingway very classically had this
very simple sort of style um there's most of the
screenwriters on the that make the blacklist every
year have a pretty visceral sense of their voice
so if you look at you pick three scripts from the
blacklist and you look at their first couple lines
on their first page you're going to probably
see slight differences in cadence in the way
they they talk and it's just you feel it it's
weird because it's it's cadence is different
it's a rhythmic thing um uh and you know word
choice plays part of it but it's just sort of a
it's a rhythm i think the first time i thought
about i learned about that sort of thing was um
spike lee um one of his books you know his first
you know how i made this how i made she's gotta
have it whatever that book was but it was um i
read the book and i was like oh this is exactly
the way spike talks and like interviews and
stuff and i was like oh you can do that you're
not supposed to write this kind of fakey fake
format that you learn in school and it was like
and it was so it just felt more personal you know
so i think screenwriters that have a great voice
they describe those action scenes with um not so
much like so strongly there but like there's a
sense of their cadence in this genre in service
to this particular story so i haven't read a
spike screenplay in a while so i don't know
exactly what he does on the page but i would
imagine it's i mean the thing i read of his was
nonfiction so it was very much his voice but
voices is great it's probably one of the things
that um again most of the scripts that make the
blacklist every year are are mostly powerful in
in voice um and then somewhat in concept although
some of the concepts are not very strong and then
they can execute but i in my ucla extension class
we would often teach a lot of those screenplays
from the blacklist and very interestingly they um
the ratings were all over the board it wasn't like
you know i wouldn't tell them which one's wrong
sometimes i would sometimes i wouldn't but like it
didn't matter there was literally um some of the
scripts they hated the most the class blacklist
scripts wow it's it's there's so much subjectivity
in the business so you just have to know how to
getting back to that feedback system you know how
to take subjectivity out of it you need enough
data points so that it's not um one person is
never making or breaking you or one contest or one
whatever you need enough data points so that um
subjectivity is not a significant factor i think
kevin smith too has a very distinct cadence for
his writing and in his book and um that's right
when you talk about muscular words can you give me
an example of a weak muscular word versus a strong
one um so um muscular is sort of like the opposite
of um pat you know passive to a passive active is
more different but you can say passive or active
and active even more muscular so um we are talking
right it's a passive way in a very bland way um
um we are enthralled in conversation and maybe
that's even a little too flowery but right but
we are um digging into the meat of the craft
of screenwriting you know you can feel the
difference between those different word choices
and the amateur will do things like we are talking
and and that's why you can see it in one one
sentence and then you might have somebody
who's getting look again you know the other
thing i said about enthralled or whatever
that might be a little bit too flowery right
um but you'll see the um the writers that
have that voice there's there's a poetry to it
it's just beautiful it's just enough sort of
flourish on it's not too fancy or sometimes
it will be uh there was a guy that wrote um
uh friday's name but he um anyway any great
screenwriter has really distinct cadence and voice
if we posted a video entitled the
writing advice which changed my life
would it be save the cat or something else um
for sure if i had to pick one most influential
theorist on my career by a long shot it was blake
snyder him personally and his system because i
read the book i was like wow this is amazing
i took his class and i was like he's amazing
and um it just was so robust and actionable
and easy and accessible and didn't take
himself seriously and just helpful and it was
like oh yeah it was this was how i was trying
to serve my audience and he's got so many good
ideas on how to serve them better than i was
taking what i already did
that was great and then um
making it more or sort of allowing me to be more
articulate in the way that i was serving them
and then um a couple years after that that i
took his his seminar um i had won this contest
and part of um winning that contest with this one
screenplay that i wrote with this other writer
and he hadn't taken blake's seminar class as he
was so like oh and i did it once and i was like
i'll do it again and that was actually after blake
had died unfortunately so i was curious about how
somebody else would teach his class and my writing
partner hadn't um uh taken his seminar at all but
we were both using that system we're a fan so we
went back and and did it with another instructor
who was also wonderful it was blake but he was
wonderful and interestingly the story that we
broke that weekend we actually sold we set it up
how long did it take you to write it well we broke
you know his weekend seminar because you go in
with start with a log line and you end with um
your 15 beats at the end so um we broke the sort
of the you know the structure of it then and then
we probably did i don't know i'm sure a month or
two of sort of breaking it out and then my guess
is we probably had and then lots of drafts it was
probably after that weekend probably three months
after that we probably had a draft we
had a producer attached to that already
and we were going to make that one ourselves
directed ourselves um but the producer was like
dude this guy this is really good we i think i
can get this set up someplace else and we said
great so then we um end up and that's the script
that got me assigned to uta and then we started uh
taking around ended up getting set up and uh that
was great how did you meet that producer i went to
nyu with him oh nice okay so alumni pays off yeah
uh it did in this case it did in this case i mean
my look i feel i have some strong mixed feelings
about nyu i generally experientially i loved it
um it was you know some of my favorite times i
have lots of favorite times in my life but i i
really enjoyed it um the cost of those programs
generally doesn't sort of pay out the return on
that investment to me feels out of whack um uh
so um so there's that and people that are doing
undergrad probably you can justify a little bit
more but those mfa programs are really expensive
and um and people if they have the money awesome
that's great um but if they're taking out those
loans for those programs that's a heartbreaker
because um you know no matter how good you are
that's just a big burden uh so the logistics of
that is is i think um really problematic um so uh
but i like the simple experience and partly a
lot of people talk about the people that you
meet there right so if nothing else because it's
you know nyu is seen as some people consider it
the best film school certainly one of the best
um people are then attracted to it for those
reasons i want to go where the best is right
so so i met really great people there and um
and so that made a big impact and this was one
producer that i did but the truth is if i were
to go back i wouldn't go to film school if i was
rich i wouldn't be fine but i wouldn't because
i would have maybe hung out at sundance and been
a volunteer there and met those same damn people
that way or um you know there's lots of different
ways to meet people which is important and that's
people say well film school you can meet people
great but like you're meeting people and you're
paying an arm and a leg for it so um there's
there's other ways to meet people that are
at that ambition level that that you might be
attracted to if you want to do really sort of
world-class work which you'll get at usc nyu
afi those places um but there's other places to
meet those same people um and when you show up
with your power or your superpower who you are
you find people you find the right people and
the people that aren't your type you just you
know get filtered out yeah and the thing for gen
xers like you and i is that social media wasn't
around crowdfunding wasn't around and it's so
valuable now because you can meet so many people
let's suppose you have a successful campaign
now you need an editor you can find somebody
another country and and they can you know but
but those options weren't available at that time
a totally different world so i mean you know
your youtube channel is one wonderful way of them
you know democratizing it i mean the information
you guys have one person after another with
these really great ideas um just makes it so
much more accessible for all sorts of people
um you know and makes you know justifying the cost
for those really expensive you know film programs
especially the mfa programs just you know again
if you've got the money it's awesome it's a great
one-stop shop and you can have some forge some
great memories that you're you're not going to
get other places so you know in terms of making
a film together and and watching it together so
if a writer is being ignored by hollywood is that
a sign that possibly their work is just not ready
yet maybe it's a great question so um there's
two things going on here um most likely they're
probably not ready that's that's more likely
and because subjective business it's entirely
possible that work is totally ready and just
hasn't found the right person at the right time
so how do you know which one is you with your
script that's when you come back to this idea of
a high quality feedback system right so first your
internal system with where you're developing it
and then when you get it to the point where you
feel like it's as great as you can make it then if
you're an amateur you go to screenplay contests
or blacklist.com or spec.tom and specscout.com
or coverfly really great places to see where you
stack up and the metrics i generally suggest are
10 places it could be an industry it could
be somebody that works it could be a friend
of yours that's an intern at such and such
production company it could be one of the
contests it could be one of those screenplays
exchanges that i just mentioned any of those
things if it's somebody in the industry that could
be like oh my god this is the best script i ever
read i'm going to turn around and give it to
so and so and they could do something with it
that to me counts as an open door if it's your
friend who went to film school with you that
doesn't count because unless that person's
you know spielberg's kid or something right
so um it's got to be somebody that has the
agency to sort of move it move it forward
out of 10 data points whether they're in every
contest everyone is like cool contest every
contest has an opportunity to break your career
they don't exist they're there to try to help you
right you know there's one or two scams out there
but by and large they're trying to help you they
want your script to be amazing so um so they're
all data points so you if you submit to 10 places
in the industry contest exchange whatever and at
least three out of the ten only three out of the
ten you are getting an open door then you're
actually in a good place at that's the minimum
right and by that means an open door is you
advance in that contest you get maybe a seven
on the blacklist or you're pretty high in the
specs out but you're basically you're getting to
the point where either that organization is like
oh we want to keep you listed on our site because
we feel like we might want to take credit for your
success right anybody advances that's what they're
doing if you uh submit it to your friend who's
working at such and such and they submit it up to
the producer and like oh this is interesting we're
not going to set this up but maybe you come in for
a general meeting or the next thing you write
right that's an open door anything that's sort
of that counts as like a longer term relationship
escalation that counts if you don't get it if you
get um rejected by the screenplay if blacklist
gives you a three if whatever if if it's a closed
door um then it's just a data point no big deal
okay it's a data point so when you then you look
at those data points and if you're not getting
if you're only getting one or two out of ten
you know it's probably because the material is
not close and then you go back and you go okay
well i thought it was close here's what i'm doing
here's what my comparable movie's doing what's the
difference how do i close that gap you close that
gap by a high quality feedback loop people that
know what they're doing people that'll give you
a sense and then you'll figure out and then you
go back and you resubmit right if you are getting
um more let's say you're you know five at it like
half you have a great script and half the places
you submit to you're you're advancing or maybe
you won one outright right great so now you're in
a different place now you're for sure ringing the
bell and now it's a numbers game that's when you
double down and i did this myself when i was first
starting out and entering contests we had a script
me and this one writing partner and it made the
quarterfinals of the nicholl fellowship and i was
like oh that's nice so um i'm going to double down
15 more screenplay uh contests to that for that
script right because i already knew that it was
proven and and so then i had 16 data points and
what happened eight of them were open doors of
some sort and eight of them nothing and one of
the things that breaks my heart is like writers
come up to me like yeah you know i submitted my
script like two or three places and like you know
i only got into one or whatever but they they
don't they're not taking subjectivity out of it
you need data points right so of that one script
and one of those scripts we won the grand prize
we run ten thousand dollars so if our script we've
submitted to three of those places by chance and
they all got projected and we just gave up this
left ten thousand dollars on the table right so
uh so you got to take subject heavy subjectivity
out of it by getting enough data points um and so
uh and then once you have something that's again
you're getting you know fifty percent at least
thirty percent but you want fifty sixty seventy
percent of open door rate they need to buy as many
lottery tickets as you can as many festivals as
you can get that there's also other ways you can
you meet anybody you want in hollywood this idea
that the doors are closed are ridiculous because
um all you need you just need to you need to know
how to entertain your way into talking to people
i mean that's the truth and there's way you
know and usually the way most people query
hollywood is ridiculous it's
um what you need to do is
empathize with where the other person is and
approach them with an easy ask maybe you ask them
a question maybe you look at their twitter account
you see what they're talking about but you have um
you have an organic conversation with these people
at peer-to-peer and there's lots of the doors are
wide open this myth that it's closed is ridiculous
it's closed because you haven't thought about them
you've been thinking about yourself and you don't
either don't have it in this on the script yet you
need to you know spend more time developing the
craft or um you actually have a quality project
but you're selfish in the way that you're um
approaching people you're annoying them you
know you're like a telemarketer or whatever it's
not gonna work you know but if you charm your way
you know you can even there's a guy that hit me
up on twitter who um he technically made all the
wrong decisions in terms of how to query i tell
people how to do it and when i work with them and
there's very specific ways that have a very high
success rate this guy did all the wrong ways you
know he was completely talking about himself me me
me my project whatever but it was so damn charming
and the way he did it i was like i'll give him
a pass i started talking to him and you know we
ended up you know ended up working with him so um
charm is the most important thing but like and it
can even overcome bad form but like there are just
simple ways of again getting back this idea of it
all being easy you know people are like ah i knew
this one writer who thousands of query letters and
it was partly and got like sort of no response and
partly because he um he just had that old school
approach i'm just going to shotgun all these
people and i'm going to talk about all my i got
to establish credibility so i did this and i won
this festival blah blah blah and it's just noise
it's just noise nobody wants to hear that but
everybody wants to have good conversations
so you want to talk to anybody in hollywood look
them up online see what they're talking about get
in organically get into a conversation with them
by talking about what they're already tweeting
about on twitter or whatever their charity is or
whatever they already love and let it be organic
don't be attached to it let it be easy and i
guarantee you if they are true kindred spirits
you will find something to talk about and then at
the right time they'll go wow you're fascinating
what are you working on oh glad you asked and
then you pitch but can charm really be taught
because there's some really bright people around
here and maybe they're just so used to being very
matter-of-fact they're not used to i hate to say
bsing but sometimes charm can be equated to bs and
there's a there's a there's a time for that and
and and people can do it very subtly and it works
but some people don't they're not they don't
do charm yeah what happens to those people um
so um it's a good question and um it's it's not
buyer me but it's not binary there's not you
have it or you don't it's there's a charmometer
right how far along you know and there's some
people that are off the charts that are super
charming and a lot of people in hollywood are
very charming in general it's a business
that attracts charisma and sort of thing um
but for sure there are ways we can allow that
charming charismatic side of ourselves to be
more present or less present it's a choice it's
a practice you can't just some people can turn
it on but some people need more practice but um
it's everybody's got it whether you're sort of
geeky or bro or artsy or whatever your thing is um
emo yeah it could be anything it could be anything
but like um there's a side of you that's authentic
and a little vulnerable and human and humble
and um when you show up in that energy
um in service to somebody else again
the t i was the point that i was making before is
this guy was so charming that even using the wrong
form he got my interest what i'm saying is you
can actually just even have average level charm
and if you use my my approach you're going to
get doors opening easily if you've got the goods
what happens is most people most people are
asking me how do i try out for the yankees
i'm like oh you want to try for the yankees huh
what minor league baseball team you're on oh
miners i have to do that first no no yeah dude
you can't you're not going to make the yankees
first go try out for a minor league team crush it
in the minors now you have a shot at the yankees
but that's exactly what i get when people are
hitting me up they're going well how do i i got i
just wrote a script how do i sell it i'm like wow
you might be able to sell it it might be great why
don't you submit to a couple contests and see how
you stack up and maybe it is maybe it's the best
thing i've ever read but chances are if it's the
first thing you wrote the second thing you wrote
you know you're not ready for the majors yet
probably and it's the same way it's like if you
wanna play baseball you don't be like you know i
was really good in high school i'm gonna go play
in the majors i mean maybe some phenomenal players
can play at 18 but like you know you amateur
writers don't realize levels and they don't they
don't quite realize that they're they're competing
against professionals you know professionals that
are at the game you know in in fact in the major
leagues you know you've only got this short window
of time when you can play in the majors right but
like the professional writing game you know you
could be 20 years old you're competing against me
you're paying about 70 year olds you're bringing
the lead you're competing against everybody that's
alive and can breathe and sort of think so it's
a wide pool and you have to bring your game
by understanding those levels and understanding
where you really are and then moving forward and
it's not a bad thing it's not a big
deal to be like okay yeah i'm here
and i'm on this part of the road who
cares because you know what at some
point if you stay with it you will become
professional and okay that's fine and then
um it's all the process anyway so it
really doesn't matter that much that
it doesn't matter that much where you are
along the road but for damn sure it matters
that if you're at the early part of your journey
you're not thinking that you're someplace else
you know and on the flip side after you've won an
oscar after you've had a box office success after
you've had whatever you can't then get so arrogant
that think that you know it all and you're not
still learning that's where that sophomore slump
comes in that's where all that problem comes in
it's the same problem that the beginner has
they're not in the flow they're not feeling
their superpower and leading from their superpower
they're doing it enough to get in and then they
get some sort of success and they stop doing it
and they fall off the cliff explain to me data
point in terms of screenwriting so when i say data
point i just mean the numbers so if you talk about
going to 10 places in the industry that
has the potential to advance your career
um it's you know it's a way calling it a data
point is a way of sort of draining out the emotion
of it because you know i was helping with this one
screenplay contest once and it was amazing because
somebody did this the screenwriter um he didn't
his script didn't make it to the corner finals
and his response was go f yourself oh okay it's
just such a such a ridiculous it's so ridiculous
on so many levels um and to the point that i'm
trying to make here is it's ridiculous because um
it just it's one data point it doesn't matter when
any screenplay you know contest doesn't reject
that you should the sooner you forget about it
that they didn't advance your screenplay the
better off you are you're only looking for at
least three out of ten which means seven out of
ten are going to close a door and as soon as you
find out they close your door just forget about
it it doesn't matter and certainly when you get
a door closed on your face and your feelings are
hurt don't tell the people about it like you were
a child and you were petulant um because this is a
small town everybody knows everybody and um i mean
you know nobody's really going to care and i don't
even know what the guy's name was and i don't care
but like on the scale of like emotional maturity
um you know emailing a festival that you
didn't get into whatever and telling them
to f off that's pretty much the worst
response you could you could have to um
show that you have the emotional maturity to to
do well in this business do you think rejection
is like a muscle and that it's just you
learn that eventually like it's it just
doesn't it doesn't it hurt as much if somebody
punches somebody's arm it it's almost like
just the weaker arms get it but then after a
while you build it up yes and i would even say
the word rejection is loaded with something
bad the better way to think about it is um
it's just part of the process you're either
winning this way or you're winning that way
oh i thought my script was really good but i
submitted it to the blacklist and i only got a two
oh that's interesting what was it that those
professional readers saw differently than what i
thought because i thought it was amazing and then
you go in and you figure out how to close the gap
so where's the loss there's no loss there's
no rejection it's all part of the process
do you believe every screenplay a screenwriter
writes begins with their five favorite movies
um no um and they're probably better off
leaning into their favorite films to inspire
what's next for them um because our favorite
scripts our favorite films or shows depending what
we're what we're writing um spoke to us in a deep
way um because let's i mean let's look at this uh
there's tens of thousands of movies and shows that
we could have watched in our lifetime lifetime
you know one percent of them or
whatever we've actually seen so
thousands of people thousands of movies
and shows thousands of hours for sure
if you get to the point where you're
writing a screenplay you've probably seen
you know thousands of hours of content so of that
let's say it's a thousand just for hypothetical
which are the favorites and why are those
the favorites and then when you get down to
the specificity of my favorite seven films it's
not going to be like anybody else's favorite
seven on the planet so you're talking about a
very specific almost code of what speaks to me
and if you take a look at that there's connective
tissue in terms of theme or character arc or
genre um or just feel or tone or things and it
it's um i found very instructive for me and for
writers that i mentor to use that as the well i
mean this is what they could have picked anything
right they could have you know but the ones that
they saw and of the ones they saw these are the
ones that sort of stirred their soul so why would
you not use that as a resource to say this is what
i love most and now i'm going to do my version of
that sure what if we're at a risk of putting too
many let's say we're taking from black swan or
we're taking that you know from the opening of
forrest gump or what you know we're infusing too
many things that have already been done and people
can spot that and say yeah you were that that's
derivative right we recognize that so the um
what we're always looking for is the same
but different if for um if it's too much the
same what you're talking about then it feels
too derivative it's boring right if it's too
different um it's just it's too kind of weird it's
too idiosyncratic and it's like whatever right um
the stuff that's speaking to you most deeply has
a beautiful balance of the same but different
someplace right in the middle and when i create
my new version of the same but different um
that's where the magic is i mean that's
really really profound beauty is um if i
try to do that and it's feeling derivative then
i've just leaned over to this poll too much and
i need to go okay i'm borrowing
too much from my favorite stuff
how do i make it more personal to
me what was going on in my life
that inspired me to like
that movie what is it that
you know so if you look at something like star
wars right none of us were star fighters or or uh
you know what do you call him um he's a fighter
pilot or whatever it was um for the rebellion
but like the way like in episode four i'm
talking about the way that he um interacted
with his his families and uncle and the way he
kind of was like you know had to do his chores
and then um he had this calling to go on
this adventure to face the uh the empire
we relate to that because if we do if we relate to
that we're living because we feel similar things
in our own sort of experience right so um so if
episode four is on my list of favorite movies um
you know you might take that it's sci-fi from it
you might take that it's a hero's journey story
you might take that it's um that he kind of had
this mundane sort of teenager type life and he
was called for some more sort of adventure there's
different things that you can take and if i take
x from it and i'm putting at my screenplay and i'm
getting a reaction from people i respect who are
going yeah this feels like it's too close to star
wars then it's like okay that's interesting how
do i make it more personal to me you know because
what i'm probably not doing is going deep enough
into what i love about this that material can i
give this a try with some of my favorite movies
one of them being forrest gump i might just be
forrest gump um i mean i saw it when it came
out but it's such a iconic film so i have some
thoughts on it um if that were on um uh somebody's
list of favorite movies you know you might take
away again the thing is to look at the whole
series right um if you look at seven and let's say
all of them are fairly similar to forrest gump um
there's a there's a playfulness in that there's an
innocence it's sort of i mean blake would call it
the full triumphant story um and so i would
you know i would look at that type of story
i would look at the type of protagonist that
was sort of a special needs protagonist this
idea that life is nothing but a box of chocolate
so that's a thematic idea that might speak to you
the setting it was like in the south right
in like georgia or some place or alabama
so i would take those elements and just note them
so that's a soft easy process and then list your
other six favorite movies um and then you start
looking about like are there any other movies
that are full triumphant type movies from blake
snyder's professor or any other movies that are
sort of set in the south or any other movies
about um characters that had special needs
or any other movies that have
thematic idea of sort of you know um
you know like like life is like a box of
chocolates or whatever that was or um you know
they talked about there was sort of a nostalgia
stuff going on in there too so you just take the
pieces and you start looking through it so um and
then you will see connective tissues and you'll
realize i'm drawn to these things for really deep
reasons and when you come with your new material
you create your new material from those deeper
reasons it's almost certainly going to be more
resonant more singular and you are speaking
to that as a creative authority on what you
love the most because those your favorite damn
movies and you can talk about them all day long
as an authority and so when you come from that
sort of swagger and love and passion that's
exactly what hollywood is looking for they're
looking for you to be the creative leader on your
sensibility because that's what we're doing when
we tell a story we're leading millions of people
on this journey from here to there and we can't
do it unless we're comfortable and confident
about what our sensibility is so listing your
favorites and analyzing them as a way of sort of
making you already know what those are but you're
bringing it to a conscious level to go yeah
i love these things and here's why i love
them and i can talk about them with authority
and from that authority you put that on the page
and then it crackles in your own unique way and
speaks to other people about uh russell
crowe and i'm just forgiving you the name
it's where he's the tobacco inside insider yeah
fantastic yeah so if that was on the same list
as um uh forrest gump so one connection
i'm seeing with that movie is you have
you know also kind of the both of them
have like this innocent kind of flustered
um main character i mean well yeah you know tom
hanks character isn't flustered but he runs and
crazy doesn't stop running but the um the
russell crowe character is totally flustered
and overwhelmed and so to me those are very
significant so if those are two of your favorites
i would say there's something about being sort of
in over your head less you know sort of that fish
out of water thing but like um but just sort
of innocently kind of stumbling into something
and like being like a really big deal um so
those to me are pretty significant and um
with insider there's also i mean that's
politically charged um it's socially social issue
charged um that one is grounded to michael mann um
perhaps at his best one of my favorites from him
and you got pacino who's um this
you know dynamic um sort of crusader
uh and you have that beautiful
scene in the courtroom of um
so good that well that one actor i don't know his
name but he's in that courtroom scene and he just
he sticks to the tobacco company he was just
basically like look you knew this was wrong
you did it anyway it's now gonna stop you can't
push you can't bully us anymore so it's that
that bullying thing so maybe that's the theme
in you so again those are just two movies if
you brought out the other five you can start
seeing some really significant connective tissue
and then if you you can almost see it like a lego
set right you're the lego set of your favorite
movies and then you take that same lego set and
then you create your own new movie with those
same legos and maybe you add a few new ones
but like you are much more likely to to write
something that is so connected to like your soul
for the reason that you came to the planet that
the thing that who else are we going to go to
about those movies but you because they're your
favorite movies you can teach anybody something
about those movies because your favorite so that's
sort of the way that i help people get aligned
with their superpower or where i do myself for my
own work if i get a little bit kind of confused
about something or resistance i'm like well
how are they doing at my favorite
movies and i got to look at that
and i learn and i go okay well they did this and
they did this and they did this and i go well i'm
doing this this and this and then it's like okay
well how do i make those dots connect how do i
connect apples to apples with my favorites um and
and then once i do it for me i give it to somebody
else and i go are they seeing it you know because
if it's just me if i'm a professional it can't be
just me it's got to be eliciting the reaction the
other people too which is even more fun anyway
can you explain the three elements of creating a
horror movie yeah it's a great question that comes
from blake snyder's idea about the monster in
the house because blake has this really wonderful
elegant way of thinking about genre that's
different than what most people think about genre
when most people think about genre they think
of sci-fi or western or horror or this or that
or the other and blake was like well it
doesn't really help you write a screenplay
what's a way of thinking about genre a way of
sort of unified elements that's going to keep
you focused on what's map what matters for you to
create a screenplay with core elements that has
like the tuning fork that sounds like wonderful
expression of that genre so um one of my favorites
is that monster in the house genre and and that
requires a monster of some sort right um but it
need not be like supernatural could even be like
a psychopath or or you know something terrible
and then a house that's um that's confined the
protagonist so that it's um so they can't get away
right so that the monster is chasing them because
if uh there's no house then there's no tension
right the stakes are there because they can't get
away from the monster because they're stuck in the
house together and then the most fascinating
part about it is the sin that's the third part
and the why is sin and it's because
monster monster in the house movies are
a morality tale of when we when you
do something bad bad things happen
so uh you know the classic um you know kids tight
teenagers go into the woods to have pre-marital
sex well then the bad thing's going to happen the
slasher is going to come out and kill them right
but without that sin they're just kind of you
know a couple walking their dog by the woods
and they get killed it doesn't quite doesn't
quite hit us in that same way because we're all
attracted to sin and we all sin to some degree or
another and so monster in the house stories play
on that vice choice and terrible response and
that's part of the titillation of great horror
and what's also really wonderful about what blake
thought about in that theory is that he then said
if you look at a movie like jaws um where the
monster is the shark and the contained the house
is the cont is the island where you know the
sort of the amity island which was sort of like
the hamptons but like you know this contained
place um and then the sin was that um
they knew the threat was there but they didn't
shut down the town or didn't keep people away
from the beach because it was a tourist town
and they needed the money or they wanted the
money the greed was the same so that makes the
that's such an interesting story and compelling
in a different way than if it didn't have that
element but then blake really ingeniously said
a movie like fatal attraction he would
also put in that monster in the house
things what you know certainly jaws is like a
horror movie but how would you fail attractions
like this kind of psychological thriller but let's
look at the three elements you've got the monster
which is glenn close playing the psychopathic
woman who just was obsessed with this guy
you've got the house was literally the
end was the house but it was really
kind of the family unit right and the
sin was adultery so you have that same
primal pattern of you know wanting
something that you really shouldn't go after
and you do it anyway and it brings out
the monster and then all hell breaks loose
great example so that doesn't necessarily have to
be a horror film it can be a thriller it could be
a drama um i mean did you see dark waters i didn't
see doctors oh okay all right we'll go into that
one yeah but it it can it absolutely can transcend
what traditionally we think of as genres it could
be sci-fi western it could be anything um the
key is to blake's mind which i thought was really
great was that core pattern you're gonna chances
of making a writing a script that makes a deeper
impact on people is is much more likely if you
take those three elements and you sort of build
your story around those elements no matter
what sort of external genre you place on it
does every genre have a certain amount of elements
a writer must know yeah yeah they do it's um
because what what we're doing is we're taking the
audience on a very personal journey even if it's
a comedy or whatever it is um and the genre
is the set of expectations that the audience
is has been promised for them
to plunk down their money
to see the story so if i promise them a comedy
and it's not funny they're going to be pissed off
and rightly so um if it's a horror movie it's got
to be scary it's a thriller it has to have tension
and so a lot of beginning writers don't realize
that they're not seeing it as a relationship with
the audience with these promises and genres are
all about promises and expectations and sometimes
beginning writers will go oh
i've got this cool idea and
it's kind of this genre and it's kind of where
that genre and it's kind of like that and it's
like yeah that's really creative and um you
are planning to alienate your audience um
and it almost never works um there's some
genres that can kind of um play nice together um
uh you know one that a lot of people try to do
but very very rarely get get right is like horror
comedy um edgar wright i think does it masterfully
better than anybody that i've seen but it's really
hard and it's really hard because comedy is so
particular and so the comedy has to be great and
then the amount of fear and the scares has to be
great so you're talking about two really high bars
that are particular that's why most don't work
well and i think that getting back to the other
point is that just early screenwriters sometimes
when i when i work with screenwriters they um
it's one of the ways that their creativity
gets in the way that they um it's like they um
they're building a car and they put triangle
wheels on the car and um that car is not going
to go it is going to be super creative it's going
to be really cool and i honor them for coming up
with those ideas but um it's not going to get them
to where they want to go so um there's ways where
you just you know don't you take the round wheel
you can make a big round wheel or small round
wheel but make it a round wheel um and then the
creativity on top of that then you can go wild
so there's um yeah that's a common problem that
earlier writers have they don't know which boxes
can be totally crazy and need to be crazy and and
different and which boxes are really more like an
engineering problem they just don't mess with that
and genre is absolutely one of those ones where
you generally don't mess with it you go you
give them what they want and give them a spin
on it but it's really what they want um you know
even tarantino who has a deep understanding of
movies and genre you know one of his i think least
successful movies was um from dusk till dawn that
he made with rodriguez and i think it was just
because it was it was a horror crime film and it
started literally started out as i think more of
a crime film and then took this crazy left turn
into a vampire movie um which even just saying it
sounds like one of those hey wouldn't it be cool
and then it was like this and then these
vampires came out you know and um you know
those guys were at a point in their career
where they were killing it and um they're
like yeah this is really cool and they loved it
and you know and people you know uh i don't know
if it was profitable probably it might have been
profitable or not i don't think it was or maybe
over time it became profitable but like ultimately
i think it's a really good case study of
an interesting idea um but a fairly low ceiling
in terms of how many people are really going to
love it and i'm sure some people are like i
love that movie it's my favorite okay great
and if your objective is to deliver your voice
and service to your audience as powerfully as
possible for as broad of an audience as
possible stick to one genre and nail that
genre and go take that genre to the new place
give it a fresh spin on where it's going next
the audience gaining trust the screenwriter
gaining trust of their audience is is
it different than this genre promise
no it's the same the one way to establish
trust with the audience is if i you know
i've shown them a log line and it's this
particular genre and on page one they're seeing
that it already feels like this genre on page one
now i'm establishing more trust and if i'm paid
if i'm if it's a comedy and there's nothing funny
on page one problems and what about this i hate to
call it self-delusion but i'll just use that for
lack of a better term of a writer thinking they're
taking genre to new heights but they're not really
doing that they're mixing it they're they're
playing with it in ways that really aren't
taking it to new heights so i love that
question because um it to me it feels like their
intention is dead on and the execution is a mess
so um if they have a high quality feedback loop
system um it will tell them you know it'll be like
look i wanna i think i'm gonna have some action
and i'm gonna have some comedy and i'm gonna
do this i'm gonna have that and um the response
to that sort of thing is like look this is
it's kind of like a little bit of a lot of
things and i'd rather have a lot of one thing
um if they're getting high quality feedback um and
then that person can go huh because i thought
it was kind of cool okay well i'm gonna make
it anyway if i'm an independent filmmaker and
then it'll play regional festivals or whatever
or not at all but like if you want to blow people
away then you do sort of less from a deeper place
and you fulfill that promise of genre of
these other things in a way that's profound
and feels fresh and new so it's the same but
different it's familiar but fresh um and uh
yeah genre is is one of the best ways to
do it and so the person that's kind of like
in that scattered place where they've got all
these mishmashes um again it's fine you know
but they just have to just compare the apples to
apples i'm trying to you know here's a comparable
again they're if they compare one apple that
they're trying to do with four different
apples that's the problem right no give timmy
one movie that had this particular genre that
you love that was successful that you you'd love
to have that sort of success with your screenplay
what's that apple how you create your apple and
then you figure out how you sort of can make
them the same so quentin tarantino tells this
great story about when he was acting in the 80s
and uh he had this acting and at that
point in 80s you know you couldn't get
there was no internet so he couldn't get scripts
online he had to kind of like watch the movies and
you know take notes and so he's in his acting
class and he um you know wrote down the scene from
this movie and handed it to his acting partner
and goes like you know we're going to act in this
in the scene together and um and the scene the
right scene partner goes well holy [ __ ] this
monologue isn't in the movie and quentin's
like what oh geez i'm sorry he goes no no this
is better than what's in the movie and so um the
takeaway there for the for the amateur writer is
um what he did inadvertently was realize that he
as a writer was nailing at a really high level
so um amateur writers can use or any writer can
i use it all the time to sort of compare apples
to apples with any sort of element if i'm trying
to get better at let's say tension or you know
certain dialogue or genre whatever i look at what
i think is the standard for what i'm trying to do
in another thing and then i do my version of it
and i try to get the apple to the apple to be
the same in my view and then i get feedback and
are they looking at it and going yeah brooks i
can't tell which one was written by you and which
one was written by you know legend a or whatever
now now i'm good it's like fan fiction
almost was doing an early version of it yeah
yeah that's right that's right it was a good look
at it that's exactly it and if you can do fan
fiction that's as good um you know i mean yeah i
mean there's you can you can get work that way if
you can play in that universe in a way that's as
powerful as the you know the people already there
sure so if i'm writing let's say a thriller and
i think oh wow i'm gonna really this is this
the thriller genre but i'm gonna take it to new
heights and let's suppose it's like a wall street
corruption story and somebody is the cleaning lady
and she ends up seeing people shredding documents
but then the people that are really the
bad guys turn out to be like reptilian
society people and that's i'm almost that's not
really taking it to a new height that's mixing
genres because now i've got some sci-fi in there
and they don't need to be reptiles you see what
i'm saying so i'm mixing but i my assumption is
i think oh i'm going to take this to new heights
but if i don't get that feedback from the feedback
loop then i'm going to be delusional and thinking
that this is just like never been seen before
so so what i'll say about that is yeah i think
that the word delusional is sort of a charged
word that feels a little distracting because
in this hypothetical where somebody's like
i'm trying to take the genre to a new place
perfect that's exactly what we're doing that's
exactly what everything is that we love has done
it takes something not everything but a
lot of things that really break ground
it's because they're doing that so that intention
is dead on and the truth is it takes trial and
error to be able to get that it's like i want to
make the best new heist film ever right awesome um
that's what i'm trying to do where am i at now
so to say where i'm at how is delusional i was
like okay fine but like i mean it's kind of a
negative way of saying it's just like you you are
where you are and then and then you just kind of
figure out here's what i'm trying to get to here's
where i am now how do i sort of get there and
um and being gentle with ourselves and thinking
of ourselves or other people is like delusional
is kind of a it's a distracting way of of the
matter-of-fact business of getting the apple to
match the apple and if um and the impulse to go
the way that i'm going to take it to that next
level is adding a bit of this genre that genre um
maybe it's just you know it's it's sort of like
um you know just you know get a feel for these
things you know i mean it's like sometimes some
genres do have aspects that do play nice together
you know or harmonize really nice together um
and some things kind of clash you know they're
sort of um you know somebody can you know do a
website design or just a set of colors and some
people have a knack for like those colors look
nice again or like the way you dress you know
some people can do it some people can't
people like it and we don't but like
it's that set of artistic choices that
harmonize together or not and so um
so uh it's a matter of playing with which story
elements end up harmonizing in the right way
to get to the point where you're taking the
genre the next level so i would never describe
it as delusional when they're in the process of
doing the damn thing that they should be doing
brooks we're going to give you 14 idea fragments
you don't have to use everything you don't have
to use all of them you can throw any of them
away except one and we want to see how far you
can get into the process while taking us through
your process the best you can and for those of
you watching if you want to play along at home
great please do the same and we welcome you to
pause the video and see what you can come up with
and compare your ideas to a professional writer
okay are we ready i'm ready okay screenwriters on
your marks so here we go 14 idea fragments single
mom single mom 500 000 500k a train a train memory
loss that we lost what i forget that's right logic
a small town in michigan small town michigan okay
the power of silence power of silence a yellow bag
yellow bag a man with a checkered coat
man with a checkered coat two friends
who haven't seen each other in 20 years two
friends who haven't seen each other 20 years
an abandoned castle and uh abandoned castle
butchered that spelling of abandon that's fine
okay a life-threatening dare a life threatening
dare a mismatched pair of detectives a mismatched
pair of detectives rebirth rebirth
and lastly this piece of dialogue okay
they don't realize how powerful i am
cool
okay great so the first thing i'm thinking
about is what spoke to me like when i go down
these prompts it's like what is it um where
where do i feel like i might have a personal
take on something right single mom um my mom
was single so that i feel something 500k is a
significant amount of money
um maybe i mean it's sort of
you know heists and crass and it's sort of
material and maybe trane is a great location
certainly a big history in um cinema history
of trains or strangers on a train or lots of
different i actually wrote up the first screenplay
that i wrote was a passenger that i that i sold
was commuters on the l train in chicago getting
trapped in the blizzard during an alien invasion
so um but i can't do that i already wrote that
one so um that's that memory loss is certainly
interesting um but not so much to me i'm gonna put
that one aside um small town michigan okay maybe
um certainly i spent some time in the midwest so
that's possible but probably more toward the end
of the list doesn't i'm more called to the train
and then you later have a location with the um
the castle an abandoned castle which is kind
of interesting um i visited england once
and um went to see a castle and it was it's
interesting it's what's nice about that it's an
elevated location it's sort of just it could
be a warehouse right but it's you know has this
history and um and it has all these metaphorical
powers to it so maybe there's something there um
power of silence that's interesting um one
of the things that makes cinema powerful
is um you can just watch what people are doing and
you can um it can it can hit you on a deep level
uh scorsese said uh once someplace that i really
appreciated he he would sometimes watch his own
films if they came on tv or whatever and he
turned the sound off and just kind of watches
his shot selection which is a really good
way to focus on your subtext what are the
characters doing what do they want also it's a
great way to make sure the scene construction is
is muscular and powerful if you had the sound off
um could you see what the conflict was and what
are they doing so um yeah so there's something
there certainly lends itself well a yellow bag
i mean that was going to be used to pull over
somebody's head to kill them okay otherwise i'll
feel connected to that man with a checker coat
that sounds like something potentially could
be in some sort of detective piece or whatever
i'm not that called about that two friends who
haven't seen each other in 20 years um i am all
over that um i had deep relationships with people
i went to high school with um and childhood too
and that's probably pretty common but there was
the the i uh in nyu my senior thesis film was
about me uh was based on when i took my girlfriend
home to my hometown and i had really close
relationships with my guy friends and i kind of
got myself in a situation to be choosing between
my girlfriend and my guy friend ended up winning
a screenwriting award there um so that's um
to me that's the most loaded and interesting
idea of everything so far right and who knows
maybe this is two single moms who haven't
seen each other in a long time and maybe
they're on a train and maybe they're gonna
rob the train for five or thousand dollars
you had a terrible idea but anyway that's just
um that's not where i'm going but um single
moms haven't seen each other in 20 years i
mean i'm not a single mom so i wouldn't go too
far into that as my protagonist probably um
i can i write women they're half the people on
half the characters in all my screenplays so i
can um like these days me being a white straight
male um writing a single mom driven movie is
you know there's resistance there um and it's it's
other people's story so um uh the son of a single
mom my bad that i get that's personal to me um but
these two friends haven't seen each other 20 years
they meet on a train is definitely something that
is speaking to me see single mom maybe um maybe
one of them is traveling with their single mom
that feels personal to me um and maybe they're
going to see this abandoned castle in london
right or outside of london so now what i'm doing
is i'm taking these elements and i'm connecting to
things that have happened in my life that i could
bring out authenticity with i could make them
something that it's like what's my personal way
in when i write with this one writing partner um
you know his superpower is sort of creativity and
inventiveness and he loves sci-fi and fantasy
my superpower is grounded characters person
grounded personal characters and i write
tension that's really thick generally in
dramas or thrillers so when i write with him it's
like where's the double filter where do we both
um like when we both speak to so um uh and
so sometimes when we're looking at fragments
it's sort of you know when he and i are maybe
brainstorming new concepts or when i brainstorm
myself i kind of take fragment ideas and i kind of
start and if he and i guess the reason i brought
up is he and i are disagreeing about something
he like kind of likes something i go yeah but i
don't have any personal connection to it and then
we go okay fine i'm going to the next one or vice
versa so that's what i'm looking for here when i'm
seeing these fragment ideas it's like what's my
what's my personal connection to it if i'm in
a general meeting with a producer or something
like i got this book and we're thinking about
bringing in a writer to adapt it or whatever
um i go great let me hear it and i'm looking
for some sort of connection because um
i can make it sing when i'm writing about this
dude i went to high school with who fascinates me
you know that that's really what i'm
writing about and i'm just sort of
doing it in this certain way that kind of
connects so um okay a life-threatening dare
probably not a dare doesn't interest me um
i'm putting that at the bottom of the list
next in yellow bag which i won't use a mismatched
pair of detectives well that's sort of if i was
working with like a producer who was like i want
to do a movie and it's got to have a mismatch
all right i might you know it's part of the you
know like maybe these two friends they meet on
the train they haven't seen her in 20 years and
something terrible happens on the train maybe
it stops in the middle of the woods or something
and um they have to be a mismatched pair
of detectives to figure out what the hell
happened um you know i'm just kind of i'm
there's two things i'm doing i'm trying to say
what what is it that i can bring something to
from my perspective on life um and
then how do these elements sort of
piece that together but the key is not to
force it right a mismatched pair you know
that element in general mismatch
para detective feels a little
you know a little forced to me um but it can
be really fascinating because detectives are
interesting if you're doing any sort of mystery
story and mismatch is always good because
you know we all have poles inside of us part
of us that's this and part of us that's that
and you know any sort of buddy love
story what blake snyder would call has
these two different characters learning
from each other so maybe you know these
detectives are pieces that need to learn how to
fit together so that's possible um that's possible
rebirth i mean that's kind of a theme
sure you know we all have rebirths
times but i wouldn't really force a theme
that much at this point i don't think
man with the sugar coat we're back to and
then they don't realize how powerful i am
um i mean there's definitely some juice there you
could do something with that line in a certain way
um um it's kind of a heartbreaking way to take
it if you um if the character really doesn't
believe it um the character is in this place of
going i'm not enough i'm not good enough whatever
and says they don't realize how powerful i am but
doesn't mean it at all you know um the subtext of
that is really beautiful and heartbreaking
and that would maybe um yeah anyway so um
so yeah i mean that's so you know that's
that's a little bit uh 10 minutes so this
is how i would approach it so i'm kind of i
basically um reorganize the list and put the
ones that were like the ones that i had some
sort of connection to more towards the top
and towards the bottom and for the
hypothetical if i was going to go
for further i would just you know at first
you know i mean that's not how it works i mean
working the businesses they'll say i've got this
story and maybe it has some of these elements
i mean it might there might be some sort
of novel that has those sort of elements
but this is sort of missing the narrative drive
or something so um which tends to be more the
core part of a story which is why somebody
would option a book or something um but like um
does that answer your question in terms
of how i would think about these things
in terms of putting them into a story like
if you were to take some of these pieces
whether you used just one what if you just all
you did was was build it around the two friends
who hadn't seen each other in 20 years okay you
just said okay i'm going to take that and you
know that that resonates with you because you have
close relationships with people from your hometown
yeah and so okay you can go somewhere else
so you want me to come up with a concept
based on um one of these pieces sure and if one
if one and if you say you know what actually
this yellow bag what if one of them finds 500
000 in a yellow bag and now they have a moral
dilemma do i turn it in what do i do yeah yeah
interesting um well i'll pitch an idea that um
these two friends are on the train and they
haven't seen each other in um 20 years and um
maybe they had a history of some some bad
things back in high school they did maybe
not too bad but like some trouble um and one
guy's desperate and he's gotten an opportunity
to steal 500 thousand dollars from x right
so um and he hasn't seen this guy in 20 years
and he knows at least back the way he was before
that like this guy is is the perfect guy it's
almost like strangers in a train which is the
premise there or the hitchcock story was um
i'll do your murder you do my murder and
that way we have no alibi and we're both um
we're both more likely to get away with it so
maybe i would pitch this as a spin on that but
it's not um hitchcock was great but he also had
a very kind of you know bulk boxy sort of stiff
you know performances and kind of you know it was
just older different different time um but if it
was like a um yeah a modern story two friends that
haven't seen each other and this one guys already
has this heist in mind um and desperately needs
his 500 and runs into this friend and is like oh
my god this guy's the perfect guy to do it and
then what's what's the blocking agent why is um
is it the guy you know um like maybe even like one
guy's a dirty cop right so one guy's a dirty cop
and and the guy that sees him is now a criminal
and maybe he's trying to recruit one guy's trying
to recruit the other for some sort of heist
or something these guys are best friends in
high school and um so what i'm doing is i'm sort
of pitting sort of deeper personal elements in
a way that could feel kind of personal not that
i've ever robbed anything or anything like that
but like um loyalties among friends and taking
some sort of risk for a heist experience is pretty
compelling i like high stories i
like i like crime stories so um
yeah so i could see that as sort of a i mean it's
kind of a low low you know there's high concept
there's low concept um but you know it's it's
okay it's it's interesting so if you were to so
if let's say that's the story so let's say um i'll
write a log line out of it when two friends two
they were not what kind of friends
they were um outsiders they were um
two kind of down and out friends one's a
cop we were called down and out friends
um one cop and one crook who
haven't seen each other in 20 years
um meet on a train um they decide to team up to
steal 500 000 right so that's functional um but
like so that's like and that's actually where
a lot of sort of beginning writers might stop
right okay they do it and then the but the problem
is if you don't go any further with that concept
it's just flat it's sort of like i mean you have
to that dialogue would have to be phenomenal and
crackling and amazing so what really makes this
better as a concept is who are these friends is
is one's a cop what kind of cop is he how how
dirty is he and then um and if it's like this
thing where the the crook needs to the cop for
one thing and the cop needs a crook for one thing
and then there's these loyalties that are at
play and who knows maybe um you know maybe they
stopped being friends because one guy hooked
up with his girlfriend back in high school um
and then that comes up at a climatic part where
one guy never really effing free freedom for it
um you know um you know i could write a story
like that i mean again it doesn't feel i mean
i'm looking at it for 17 minutes now but like um
uh but this is the process i would go
into it and i would say what and and i
and if i was i first of all i wouldn't put a
ticking ticking clock and i would kind of play
with it for a little bit and then i would sit down
and set it down i'd go someplace else and then was
in the shower or whatever might come to me and go
okay what if what if this happened with this guy
and then what if that happened and i would play
with it and then i would get it to a point where
um you know i felt like okay this is something
that's kind of interesting and then i would pass
it around to my feedback circle say what do you
guys think is this um you know i might have them
rate it from one to ten um i might just pitch
it to them and then look at the response and if
um again i you know step one would be me getting
to a place like that i feel like i'm really
excited to me right now what i put together is
rudimentary it's like level six out of ten as a
sort of concepts right um it's much easier if
you start a new script and it's like a level
nine concept or level 10 concept right which
is unlikely for you know most people to do when
they're sitting it's looking at something for 15
minutes but that's the things we you know we don't
have to do this we have as much time as we want
so um i would just keep going back to the well and
playing with it what about this or what about that
and then you know if i ever felt a little forced
and just put it away and then just do something
else and then once i got it up to a point where i
felt like oh this is actually really great and
also the other thing that i'd be looking for
that's really good that i got from blake snyder
is irony so where could you add some irony to the
story so two down and out friends one's a cop
one's a crook they haven't seen each other in
20 years they meet on a train one guy realizes
that he's super desperate and he's got a shot
at stealing 500 000 bucks and his friend from
high school was the perfect accomplice but yeah
they you know one guy slept with this they
stopped talking 20 years ago because one guy
slept with his girlfriend and um they got to deal
with that or maybe that's got to be dealt with
upfront and then he goes okay we'll do it and that
breaks into sec into your second act um and then
as we go deeper you know why
did he sleep with the girlfriend
what did they really love about each other
um that was betrayed back then you know
what do they really need as people um
and then the movie really becomes about
uh you know i don't know if it comes about
a rebirth but it comes about them sort of
because i had deep friendships in high school i
mean these guys i love these guys because partly
because my father wasn't around as much as i
want him to be so i have abandonment stuff so
one way that i dealt with that abandonment stuff
was having really tight friendships so um uh
my friends and i did not sleep with each other's
girlfriends but um you know there's betrayals of
different sorts or whatever but i would sort of
tap into that thing and it would probably have
to do with some if i was going to write this or
develop it and i had to use those elements i would
start playing around this idea of abandonment and
how i dealt with abandonment and how these guys
have dealt with abandonment and what they do about
it and um yeah so that's kind of that's that's
what i got i mean that's sort of my process in you
know looking at it for 20 minutes um you know how
i would approach it why would i i would approach
it that way um and at the level that i got to this
what i will say is a this is like i said i don't
know 60 70 it feels like it's it's there if it's
what would make this from just being an exercise
to something like oh this is amazing i want to
really write this at some point probably another
element or two maybe there's a sense of irony that
i could bring into it or maybe a way to elevate
it maybe it doesn't take place sort of modern
day but maybe it takes place on the moon or the
international space station or something or takes
place in like the 1860s and i'm in a place where i
really want to you know explore that sort of thing
but what i'm looking for is that personal
connection to it something that i feel like
yeah i'm on the planet to do this you know and
then another thing i would do early on is going
okay well what is it like okay it's sort of like
strangers on the train but like you know i admire
stuff about that but that doesn't really speak
to me um now pat garrett and billy the kid the
peck and paw film from 72 or 73 that blows me
away and that's about friendship and betrayal
so maybe i do that maybe i go in and go okay two
friends who haven't seen each other and maybe it's
sort of like with pacquiao and billy the kid
they were outlaws together and then they were
pitted against each other um so maybe i would do
that i would kind of milk what i love from that
comparable and i would go okay how would peck
and paul do this how would this happen um so
um and again the key is not forcing it so i would
never put a 20 20 minute um or whatever never put
a time limit i would i would just get in there
and play around and that get to the point where
if it was fun to keep playing i would and if
it stopped being fun i'd just do something else
maybe with a different story maybe whatever
um and if i was in a meeting with a producer
and they were pitching this idea it would
still be the same thing it's like you know
i either can bring uh something to what
this you know the guy's vision is for what
he wants to do whether it's an original or
an adaptation or something um or i can't and
i'm not attached to either outcome you know
because it's that's the thing it's because it's
it exists beyond me it's like i'm not even it's
not me the more i think it's like me my screenplay
blah blah blah it's like that just gets in the
way what i'm doing is trying to be in service
to the audience that would want to see this
let's say it's a crime thriller or a heist film
and um and if i am the man to serve them
with these sort of ideas that just came to me
and they're in service great you know and you want
to pay me a lot of money for that awesome and um
and i'm not i'm not attached to anything but you
were able to find things that you emotionally
plugged into even if it was just 60 70 percent
there like the man with the checkered coat you
were like yeah yeah whatever abandoned castle yeah
i've been to one it was kind of cool it was eerie
but it wasn't something that you really felt like
maybe a deep connection with but the two friends
that hadn't seen each other that really and why
is because my personal life my psychology my
psyche was formed around this abandonment issue my
dad took you know my parents split when i was in
third grade my dad died when i was 17. so i dealt
with abandonment as a core issue um my whole life
and so i have world-class insights about how to
deal with abandonment in good ways and in bad ways
and everything in between so um you know you've
got abandonment issues you come to me and i'll
you know we'll have a conversation and my
stories um when they come from that place now
you know what i mean now it's like it makes some
sense right um and i can touch on other things
but like that's that was a core one for me so
that's why those friendships meant so much to me
um and i mean it was like and i would not only i
had a group of friends in high school but i had
like best friends and we were like this you know
really you know a couple different ones but like
and it was probably because i was hurting so
much because i missed my father um so um that
for a screenwriter to have that sort of insight
into whatever however your psychology works
and however your triggers work can then fuel the
choices that you make so they're loaded up so that
you're not just writing oh i'm doing an action
film it's like yeah that's that but it's actually
a metaphor for this time in my life where it
drove me crazy and broke my heart and um because
the movies that we love and shows that
we love are melting our hearts because
um the people creating them
are basically sharing their
memoirs with us they're sharing their diaries
and most intimate vulnerable places in their life
with archetypes or personified in these characters
that are iconic in a way so that i look at good
fellas and i feel like that's my me and my friends
and we never did anything with a mob i grew up on
new york but like way different side of long
island and um and there was blue color there were
similarities but again like nothing like those
guys and yet exactly like those guys and that's
because scorsese and pelegi were so specific
with the people that they grew up with and they
allowed that to manifest in a movie like
goodfellas and with such delight and specificity
that um yeah it feels like it's my story
you say andy dufresne is not the protagonist
in the shawshank redemption that's correct uh
technically the helpful way to think about the
protagonist is the one who changes the most and
has the most agency and impact on the change
so um in that story andy for sure drives the
narrative i mean he is a freight train of hope
all the way through that movie um he hopes right
in the beginning he hopes in the middle and he
hopes at the end and he has a little bit of
a doubt here and there but for the most part
he's non-stop hope he dug himself out of that
damn prison with like a spoon or something you
know ridiculous or i guess a rock hammer um red
the morgan freeman character is um i mean it's not
just that he's narrating but it's also significant
that he's narrating because he starts in despair
and he says and they get to the middle and
he's kind of picking up that this guy andy
and they've already been there 15 years at that
point picking up he's this guy andy's all about
hope and he goes hope you can't hope in
here it'll get you killed in here right
um and that's that part of us that considers hope
versus despair um and that movie represents um
red in that movie is the protagonist and he
represents how part of us can realize that um
when we choose hope in no matter what situation
especially when it's really bleak like it is in
that film um we actually liberate ourselves and
we free ourselves to the point where there's a
character named brooks and i really like that
name brooks where he gets out and um the old guy
is so you know accustomed to that the other people
and is so he kind of is sort of a happy-go-lucky
character but like he doesn't have enough hope and
optimism to be able to sort of rebuild his life
and so he turns right back to despair and ends
up killing himself really beautiful turn and
counterpoint this idea of hope versus despair
but no for sure i would analyze that movie
with um uh morgan freeman's character red being
the protagonist um and one more thing about that
story um is that when they um i believe the way
the book uh ends which is really wonderful it
ends with um morgan freeman or not more friendly
the red character in the book just saying i hope i
hope he's basically learned to hope and you don't
know if he ever sees andy and to me that is sort
of a deeper more resonant lesson that like it's
easy to hope if you know you're going to get it
the rub is can you hope can you believe can you
be open when you haven't gotten it yet and you
don't know if you're ever going to get it and when
red learns to do that even though he hasn't gotten
a reconnection with andy to me that
really hits hard so i believe they
did that in the actual movie version and um
people were pissed off they didn't like it
so they think they did they re-shot the ending
where they actually reunite and people loved it so
you know um we're in service to the
audience and i think the audience loved
seeing hope be overtly rewarded to them
it landed more deeply so when stephen king
wrote the book it was a novella okay it's part of
a wonderful novella called uh different seasons uh
stand by me that movie was it was a movie it was
a great story called the body that's kind of like
the the rob reiner film but a little darker and
more interesting um and uh so that and then apt
pupil is another one there's like four stories and
i think three out of the four were made into um
movies wow and i understand that you said
something about and you did a video on your
youtube channel about uh how the law of attraction
powers the shawshank redemption and um we can put
a link to it below here um our video but you feel
that the maybe the title of the movie hurt its
success in the initial release yeah yeah for sure
in my opinion and one of my writing partners is
one of the top marketing minds in hollywood um so
doesn't mean that i'm always wrong or he's over a
bit like he's he's good so i have a pretty good
feel for marketing stuff and my opinion is that
when you have um an unusual title like what the
hell does that even mean shawshank redemption
everybody knows what redemption means but
nobody knows what shawshank means so um
the job of marketing is you're beginning to tell
the story you never want to confuse people you can
intrigue them and i think that's why they justify
a title like that is that it's intriguing in a way
and in this case it was built on ip that maybe
people were familiar with and so they were kind of
you know letting it go but like the marketing
campaign and the title you choose is the beginning
of telling the story and the better way to tell
the story is clear this is what my story is it's
a story about this or that you know um so that's
ideal um but you know sometimes you know the
coen brothers always have kind of funky sounding
titles but like you know the cone brothers movies
get sold because of mostly them and their brand
and their sort of style their super power so um
you know there's certainly exceptions to the rule
but i think if you take shawshank redemption and
you give it a different title it makes a much
bigger splash earlier on i mean it made a big
splash later because of the reaction but i think
it um there were much better titles than that
and i think the book was the book like ava gardner
or something really really read okay we're sorry
the other other actress okay yeah and then the
shawshank or something rita hayworth and the
shawshank redemption which is fine for a novella
you know i guess i don't know anything about
book marketing um maybe no difference at all
there but in movie marketing there's so much noise
you absolutely will get a bigger audience when you
have a great title and it cuts right through the
noise in a way that totally beautifully positions
the audience for the rest of the story and it's
the beginning of the story that you tell so like
a knife you want a cutting through the noise
when you broke down the shawshank
redemption in your video
you talked about letting go of
outcomes and not being attached
if we think of a writer how should they let go
of outcomes or maybe they shouldn't maybe that's
something that's not that they shouldn't never be
too free-flowing with letting something go well um
they should always let go should
they be completely free-flowing
pretty much um but not so like loosey-goosey where
you just kind of wandering around aimlessly right
there's what we want for sort of to cross our
next career milestone as quickly as possible
we want to have a clear sense of where
we're going and conviction towards it and
a joy and an ease and a lack of attachment
and we don't ultimately it's about that
process of getting there the um it's like the
way i talk about sometimes is that it's a um
it's a treadmill you know um you're you're
jogging on the treadmill and it's a beautiful
treadmill and once you get to one milestone
guess what there's just another milestone
and then once you get to that second milestone
guess what there's another milestone right so
you're already on the damn treadmill so this idea
of i'm gonna break in well you write a screenplay
today you've already broken in essentially are you
getting paid for it yet no but the paradox is the
less attached to it and the more you're there just
to serve your audience as powerfully as you can
the quicker you'll cross the milestones
that get you to the point where they're
paying you lots of money you also
broke down in your video victim
energy when it comes to the law of attraction
and attracting sort of victim circumstances
versus empowerment energy that's right
how do screenwriters do that oh wow
uh you ever heard of this thing called twitter
um uh actually you see both on twitter really
wonderful positive powerful energy and lots
and lots of um victim choices i can't make it
to hollywood because of this excuse i'm to this
i'm to that i'm to the other they don't get me
woe is me i have no power it's just it's really
a fascinating choice that um a habit that people
have of giving away the power giving away the
power giving away the power when we have the
choice to do the opposite i'll take the power i'll
take it off you know i'm responsible i can choose
yes hollywood has bias yes some groups are more
favored than other groups yes yes yes it's all
true and you can succeed despite that how you go
apples to apples you're trying to do this you're
seeing what's already out there with this you
figure out a way to close that gap you position
yourself as the best person to do the next you
know thing in this genre the person who's gonna
write horror in a new way or this in a new way
or that in a new way and if you do that they
don't care what you look like where you came from
at all you need to deliver the goods and in fact
if you are related to a celebrity or studio head
or whatever and that door is wide open for you if
you don't have the goods you're not going to get
work either this idea that nepotism is what fuels
all these things it's bs i mean it's a factor
but it's this much of a factor what's really
a factor is delivering the goods and if
you got the goods they don't care where
you came from they don't care who you are any
type if you've got the goods they'll be happy
to work with you and will try to sell you and
if you have all the connections in the world
and you're not delivering the goods guess where
you go director jail writer jail you get nothing
and that's exactly what happens there and these
ideas of that hollywood's is closed place is bs
because of director jail you know what
i mean it's like you got to put up
what's true is that you're only as good as your
last picture that sort of thing i mean that's
um that's a negative way to spin it but
that's the truth i mean it's like um
the internet makes pretty much
anybody you want to get to accessible
you know one way or another and you're
not everybody but like most of the people
or if not not them directly probably people they
know and if you impress them but the truth of it
is um you know people just aren't developed enough
in their craft to do something that's impressive
enough to get to people who can get to people to
get it moving you know and then uh and instead of
just going okay yeah i'm on the way i'm learning
whatever they go oh hollywood's closed people
um you know they don't like my type because of
this or that and um again there is bias i'm not
saying there isn't but it's a tiny part and when
you focus on the bias you are giving your power
away you are leaking it and you are distracting
yourself from your greatness and you are
you're just out of alignment from your
deeper goal which is to be in service of
your audience which is all about coming from
your power and being there and helping them
and in the shawshank redemption some of the
character arcs went from victim attraction
attracting victim-like um situations to reversals
of that with let's say the prison warden
so he was maybe more empowered at one point
and then because of some things that he did
then it took a reverse turn whereas with
red it was so different character arcs
happen i mean how much should we be thinking
about things like that the law of attraction
in relation to our characters what are they
attracting well we shouldn't think about the
law of attraction at all unless um we like it
unless it speaks to us unless um we see real
value in it there's aspects of the way people
talk about the law of attraction that are really
sort of off-putting to a lot of people and
for good reason um and uh and if you're
you know and if your curiosity stops there
then you shouldn't be thinking about it um
it's uh it's been significantly beneficial
for me and for other people i've seen um
put it into practice things happen and it feels
good and it's fun and it's easier and it works
that's my experience people should have their
own experience and see if it works for them
maybe it does maybe it doesn't um for shawshank
redemption in terms of the victim energy the first
thing came to my mind was that character
that um cracked that first night so um
so uh andy dufresne comes in and then
that heavier character um uh was um
he cracks he was he's the one that just he
gets so overwhelmed with his fear that um
he ends up crying and i think that the guard
actually comes in and then beats him down and
he dies because of his wounds so um and that from
a looked at from a law of attraction perspective
was like he brought that on himself he was so
deeply in the habit of giving away his power
not being able to feel the terror that he felt
being in this new place that he spiraled to
a place where he made things worse and he made
things worse and he made things worse um to the
point where he actually killed him right and we
all do that sometimes and we all have the power
to do that a little bit less and a little bit less
and when we do it a little bit less so often that
we actually almost never do it we just hold our
power and we come from our power more often your
example about the warden is really interesting
so he starts out clearly with lots of power
um and then comes to a point where but he's
he's completely corrupt so he's doing it
he's not using his power in service of his
people so um why what's going on beneath that
he's ultimately he's got the material power he's
in charge but he's not he's not in alignment he's
actually he's a victim and he's he's a
victim even though he's technically in
charge and he's coming from that victim place
as a tyrannical leader because the tyrannical
leader is not in service of his or her people
they are coming from their victim energy so um
so when he falls at the end it is still saying the
same theme that it's always better to find hope
and and despair and victim energy will always
cycle you down to terrible places even if you
are and that's actually that's the connection
between the two characters is that you have
the warden who started out very powerful
but basically was in this energy of victim
and lack and i didn't believe in genuinely serving
people so he had to cheat and steal and lie
and it basically drove him into a place of
despair and that character that came in as the
the fresh fish the uh the guy that cracked under
the pressure was the same thing but he didn't
he he just his demise happened so quickly because
he came he started from a place of less power
but they both are thematically proving the the
the thematic statement of that piece that um that
when we hope we get good things when we despair we
get bad things or from law of attraction language
when we are open to our power um or we start with
the negative part when we are sort of bringing in
victim energy or lack energy or that sort of thing
it leads to despair when we bring in our power
and our flow and our ease and our belief and
our hope and our patience it leads to triumph
should so just the way people sort of use the
hero's journey yeah to as a backdrop against
their story if someone is open to the law
of attraction and whatever woo parts scare
maybe some people others are open to um what
what templates can they apply to their story
with the law of attraction geez um i don't
know if i would call it a template it's like um
my understanding the law of attraction
there's been you know people talking
about this probably for thousands of years in one
way or another but in the 20th century there was
some you know people writing about it
sort of the turn of century and then
in the last i know 20 or 30 years there's
been other people writing books about it
there's that movie the secret that that was
you know touching on it and um but it's like uh
i don't know i mean it's yeah it's more of a
it's the tool that screenwriters can take from
it is more of a mindset approach it's like look
the doors are going to close in your career for
sure how do you want to respond to that in a way
where you're like oh no the door closed blah blah
that's terrible oh i didn't get into this you
know screenplay competition or oh this person
didn't buy my script or whatever it is there's
oh this person's not returning my phone call
you have a choice in how you can respond to that
and um and when you choose to respond to that
from your inner sovereign energy as a king or a
queen saying i reached out to another kingdom and
it didn't work out fine i'll reach out to another
kingdom and then i'll reach out to another kingdom
and then i'll reach out because you know why
that's who i am i am a king and i reach out to
other kingdoms and i do business when i find my
kindred spirits and that's just it because this
is a treadmill and i'm just in it to be here
and to do things and yes at some point i'll
find the right person and we can marry our
kingdoms together and do something amazing
and until that point cares because i'm
showing up as me and i'm just doing it